act like there is I assume there is yeah
oh yeah sumo
whoa Merry Christmas ladies and
gentlemen Happy New Year Merry Christmas
it's [ __ ] on you understand me it's
Christmas Eve
you thought it was gonna be ho-hum [ __ ]
you uncle Joey Joe Rogan here [ __ ]
live Christmas Eve talking about bugs in
your house and how easy it is for the
feds they don't need a bug your house
anymore they just use your phone they
just turn them on Jamie tell me tell
them what you were telling me about that
uh the air pods there's a new setting on
the new operating system where your ear
pods you turn on this thing called live
listen and it's listening to the
microphone on your iPhone so you can
leave your phone in a room walk out and
you can use just made your own bug but
that means that anybody that can then
access your phone could probably also
listen if they have access to that I'll
know how I've already said like if we
talked to anybody that knows what's
possible with electronics they could
already turn your microphone on any time
they want bro when I was a kid I grew up
in that bookmaking [ __ ] and there was
certain bookmakers that wouldn't talk in
a room that there was a phone in the
room smart ones in the 70s yeah I'm not
talking not on the phone but if there
was a phone in the room they would leave
the room
yeah that's an icicle these guys are
super paranoid they were thirty years
ahead of their time well you remember
how they got Vince in the chin they
started bugging cars along the way where
he would walk he would walk with his
bathrobe like he was crazy and he would
give everybody instructions and he would
do it on his walk so he couldn't get
bugged anywhere so they started bugging
the cars along his walk route that's how
they got I'm gonna get you at the mic
yeah wanted the same microphone they use
in the NFL when you hear all those
tackles and grunts in the old days they
had I don't know that the parabolic Mike
takes vibrations from glass yeah so I
could just point this laser at your
glass which speakers on and it'll take
whatever you're saying in a room and
bounce it off the glass I've heard it
there's a recluse in the [ __ ] ass so
by now it's world class they could do
well there listening to everything
bring anything in everything like want
to back him on a plane you have to
assume they're watching it like I used
to go ahead and do blast of coke I would
always pull my pants down go through the
whole process like I was [ __ ] and I
wasn't really [ __ ] I just always
thought there was a camera that well
you're probably correct I've heard
things that are just horrid about Vegas
in the 80s how they had cameras in rooms
well Vegas in the 80s was all mob Vegas
and the bathrooms have cameras so as
long as you do a blast you come out
within ten minutes the cops around here
when did they um when did the mob like
officially get out of Vegas like what
the mob is still in Vegas just short
spurts it's crazy I was in New York last
week and I realized how much
construction was going on and I thought
to myself how much of that is the mob
still getting they had a tax for years
2% so if it's a 300 million dollar job
do the math on that you make it a big
chunk of that construct didn't get rich
because the construction business is
huge
you go to New York you know I can't give
you accurate numbers because I don't
know numbers are but look what the
average is for a square foot of concrete
in New York look what the average is in
Iowa I was reading something about that
the square foot of character to build
the building in New York st. the
concrete is [ __ ] insane because so
many hands are getting [ __ ] greased
you know you don't pay a job okay so you
don't pay it's like that one episode of
The Sopranos so what I do is break your
balls you're a GC you don't want to pay
me my money that's fine I said somebody
from the Union down there and instead of
me doing this come on through I gotta
stop you I gotta take your book I gotta
call the union's to see if you're paid
up when you dues we check your tire
pressure we count the low let's count
the windows on the truck recently you
got 30 trucks backed up and you're not
making any money that's how they'd shake
you down that's the shame then or you
pay me okay the trucks go through Oh
what's on them we don't care who the
driver is we don't care fees you a
non-union it's such a dirty business at
that level that's the shade down foon
drop would be the GC on the job you pay
your job runs smooth you don't pay so 2%
of it went to the moms at the concrete
tax then they had like another 2% right
off the top
it's a bid rid bid ring Big Ben ringing
where we take G we give it to Joe Rogan
no matter what the price is we inflate
the price even though Jamie comes in
three million dollars cheaper I'm gonna
give Joe Rogan that three and two more
Joe Rogan's gonna kick that to to me and
we're gonna do the job at that's three
million dollar profit plus I'm gonna
take 2% at the top of that three million
dollar profit you know what I noticed
when I was a kid I was working
construction one of the first things I
noticed it's one of the weird businesses
that's run almost exclusively by men
like manly men like the construction
guys were burly dudes with big [ __ ]
hands they worked hard and they were
like these were like rough guys but they
were running a big business it's like
all these other businesses if you think
about businesses you think about like
computers you don't think about like
rugged burly guys but computers and
construction are just as common like
everybody needs a computer everybody
needs a house like constructions
everywhere it's a gigantic business and
it's run at least in back in Boston when
I was working as a laborer it was robbed
by these big savages - [ __ ] it big
dangerous guys we've gotten more diverse
now because the unions have made you
hire more women mmm when I was now
electrician like three months in there
was a female supervisor who knew her
[ __ ] mmm my dad you know my dad was no
electrician she was a kid that was a
[ __ ] day job and men had a tough time
working for her I clicked with her she
was easy she would leave me the [ __ ]
alone sometimes men can't they just have
a real hard time with a woman I would
have worked
me out of it I didn't mind at all I
didn't give a [ __ ] I like there if
someone's great at their job too great
there's a good job just kind of a [ __ ]
what yeah and there isn't some weird
thing that a lot of guys have right you
know Phoebe rad female trainers yeah
yeah a lot of people will go for that
don't get a female trainer
Yoel Romero well the best [ __ ]
of all time what is she trailer man I
don't know man fit strength and
conditioning she was strengthening
conditioning training him in this videos
watching busting his ass will even let
guys a super savage you know make sure
I'm right about that make sure I'm right
about that because if it's not you well
it's someone equally savage someone is
just [ __ ] a super alpha we know it's
a super alpha like you well when we had
him in the podcast I was looking at him
sitting there I think this guy has built
it's not even a real person with 12
hours should get over I remember that
night we both had spots at the store and
I pulled you aside and I go what do you
really think what do you really think I
mean this is I shoot people or is this
something that I think it's genetics
super freak genetics well when we went
to heat I went to New York last week I
purposely went to a Sorrentino it's a
restaurant North burger you know run by
this dude named Jocko Jesus Christ the
spaghetti with the tiny meatballs I
couldn't even finish it but one of his
waiters was a wrestler over the raft
listen to the podcast and he was saying
how he wasn't that good he was on the
bottom floor he ate the scratch
ah and he but he goes yeah I know you're
welcome back there just last week think
about the other super athletes that have
come out of Cuba that have gotten into
MMA and boxing okay Hector Lombard dude
I'm a lot of people they might look at
Hector Lombard because of some of his
tough fights that he had in the UFC
later in his career but if you go back
and watch Hector Lombard Wayne was
rotten [ __ ] in Bellator those were
probably his prime years he was the
champion of Bellator I mean [ __ ]
smashing people smashing people at 185
pounds and then he came over to the UFC
he fought 185 but there's a big-ass
185's in the UFC man I mean Hector is
what do you think he's five not really
not only is no effect no I think I think
he's either my hider I'm 5/8 he's either
my hydras an inch taller but he's just
so jacked but he was when he was
smashing people like earlier his career
man I always wanted to get him in the
UFC I was like this guy needs to come
over he's so athletic man he would and
he's a judo player I mean it's like a
[ __ ] jacked actor is he's a you know
he was a judo player for Cuba but I'm
telling you man did you could take all
the steroids in the world you're not
gonna move like this guy moves
Josh Lombard Josh Barnett rather told me
that Hector Lombard when he went to the
gym could just do muscle up after muscle
up he never even trained it before it's
hot Jamie I'll tell ya it's [ __ ] hard
to do a muscle up he just grabs that bar
he's a super athlete he's just had a lot
of really really rough fights against
the best fighters in the world and I
really think that some of his best
fights you could say like maybe he was
tested more and I think he certainly was
tested more here in the UFC than it
wasn't belt or certainly the caliber of
competition is far greater but I also
think you know fighters have like a
window of opportunity for the most part
for most of them there's exceptions well
they can extend that window that window
the the experts seem to think the
windows around nine years this is not a
number that I invent anything phone but
I it's a number that I agree with in
terms of like the best you have you
might be able to do it for nine years
like a door the longevity of an NFL
running back is three and a half years
which blew my mind
that's crazy that blew my mind then I
started thinking about it I talk about
all the greats I thought about her okay
I'm on Jim Brown yeah about those guys I
thought about their injuries how lucky
you have to be okay now the UFC is a
fighter how many people actually did
fight in the UFC for nine years straight
so far a lot there's been quite a few a
lot but at the same time there's been a
lot of guys that have had great
potential
and by the fourth or fifth fight they've
moved on well you know everybody's
different this is the thing everybody's
different in terms their ability to
cooperate everybody's different in terms
of their style like some guys just don't
take much damage you know some like Ben
Askren perfect example never fought in
the UFC but when you watch him fight in
these other organizations thing that's
most interesting is that it doesn't take
any damage you could say he's boring if
you want to I don't think it's boring I
think it's super high-level wrestling
and you need to see how that [ __ ] would
fly against the best in the world I mean
that's why he's here now I'm very
excited about this but he's a perfect
example of like he doesn't have any
problems that guys been fighting for a
long time you talk to him he's as lucid
as they come he's articulate it's very
smart very well-educated reads books all
the time he'll send me recommendations
for books very very interesting guy so
you got those guys who like he could do
it for a long [ __ ] time because he's
not taking a beating when you start
taking a beating man pool you know some
kind sometimes guys try to get back in
there too soon and they're still hurting
you know from from a fight like a really
bad knockout or just sometimes even just
getting beaten up is were you like even
if you don't get stopped like you incur
more damage that way you know four in a
long-ass fight than you would in a quick
ko you know like in glory you know
Joseph Valtellina Doria know that cazuca
Joe he was their champion and he won the
title against marked a month after the
fight couldn't fight again because
concussions were so bad he couldn't look
at the light from an iPhone charger like
a laptop charger that little light from
that thing would would be blinding to
him he had to be like in a dark room for
three weeks CBD oil brought him out of
it well I think though fighters and what
happens during a fight I go back all the
way to Bernard Hopkins against Felix
Trinidad because you brought it up to my
attention I never even know about that
world he never came back it was like
who's the guy that went the distance
that's now Bellator fights out of G
ESPYs camp really tough guy - went five
rounds would [ __ ] what's his name and
then Rory MacDonald
Rory yes Rory after that fight that he
had he was never really the same time
the Robert Louis robbie lawler fight
fights affect you in different ways the
beating you take affects you in
different ways I want to see what the
kid that had some Barbossa fights with
next time how he comes out he took a
ferocious beating against at Edgar Edson
yeah that last fight before our Kenta
and Kevin Lee see but Rory I got to
disagree because after that fight he
looked [ __ ] phenomenal in Bellator in
his first four who was his first fight
in Bend up belt or was it Paul Daley he
D fought um but then the next fight he
did Leamas a beast though do you
Fonzie mostly baby monster man
Douglas Lima is a [ __ ] straight up
killer you know in comedy sometimes was
appalled daily yeah so he manhandled
Paul Daley right it's a very smart fight
because he fought really well on his
feet first threatened daily a little bit
on his feet and took him down dominating
him on the ground and it was it was a it
was a very impressive win but then he
fought see fighting Mousasi I think was
probably not the but you know you never
know you know you got to test yourself
there's only one way to do that and he
knows better than anybody I mean the
guys in it to test himself now he knows
that he can't beat Musashi at least at
this point his life yeah but he's a
smart kid then he's an animal to me that
guy's so no I don't say they I just
thought that a lot of times after
battles people don't come back to say I
agree on some but I don't agree with him
the guy from Texas that took GSP to the
[ __ ] zoo and for Johnny yeah yeah he
never came you know some people give it
all you got
yep don't give it all you got moment
it's how we react after that what's
gonna happen how is Kevin Lee gonna come
back yeah
again SIA quit that you always have
those questions which is a great fight
by the way amazing for though the fight
I was most excited about this weekend
was michael Chiesa Carlos
do it mmm Brian's gonna fight with
Carlos conduit you know Carlos conlou
been around for a long [ __ ] time
his name is Condit but Condit he knows
I'm his brother and I'm one of the
biggest fans and if I was a mafia I'd
hire him from the UFC a long time ago
does he's an assassin he's like he
realized John you just give him a gun
with his silence yeah and a pencil will
let him do the rest go down and you
could switch his mind quick with six
hundred thousand a week I want to say
that his UFC was his debut against Brock
Larson but that was as debut or was it
was that in the WEC I feel like that was
in the WEC I feel like his debut was
against [ __ ] was it Jake Martin Kampmann
was his debut that's okay in Nashville
they fought him natural gallenberger too
right yes Gilliam burger was out that
was Jake Allen burgers first fight in
the UFC yeah
to Jake Ellenberger was another one man
super [ __ ] dangerous for a long time
man you ever see before he fought in the
UFC when he knocked out Pele with one
punch okay oh what a beat in my office
about three weeks ago he came into my
office and he's the nicest guy I heard
you dosed him up I gave him a bong hit
of this [ __ ] that was 31% he couldn't
answer questions dawg it was like
[ __ ] he's the best the poor bastard
he couldn't know how to drive home yeah
folks at home nada was not around Rhonda
was not around it would have broke their
system for a week if you think Brock
lesner system disappeared in the [ __ ]
system whatever oh my god poor Jake
Ellenberger we took him deep I haven't
seen it but I've heard he told me go
smoke do a little and I asked him a
question after that he was just
frustrated I love him to death he's
coming back on to redeem himself and
said he's never smoking again but he
asked of his battle yeah you can't
that's too much most people yeah that's
a 3-foot bomb well not only that Joey
for most people that don't do podcast
all the time getting on your podcast is
a mindfuck I can't believe I'm here
soon here with uncle Joey holy [ __ ] and
then boom that thirty how many percent
31 that's so high this is alien hoji
this is in in just as a for people that
don't know the numbers let's find out
what the numbers actually are like what
was what percentage THC was marijuana in
the 1970s I want to say it was like 8 to
10 probably and then I'm just guessing
it's so funny how okay I grew up in New
York New Jersey so I would go to Harlem
and what we had available to us was
Panama red Columbian gold I could be
verse of verse I could be wrong on the
names and then you had from Jamaica you
had this weed called lambs bright and
then all of a sudden in the 80s this
green weed came along and they called it
sinsemilla
so I was Coppola hundred 48th Street
then he would either sell your chocolate
tie which is lambsbread or he would sell
you sense of me oh well he would put
them together and call it the master mix
if you bought ten bags or the master mix
you got one for free gave you a punch
card this is why not closing maybe a
real punch again of nineteen [ __ ]
8283 the guy was in the middle one
corner hanging out and the funny thing
was I went back in 85 he looked me
straight in the face in his light ain't
no [ __ ] weed on his block no
more dog crap like it had just converted
to crack but this is why watch him I
told you that watching that narcos
Mexico those first two episodes was so
important because it's like it's like
some colors and you watch a TV show it's
really hard to believe that one day some
Spanish got I couldn't even speak
English said hey there's not three
cameras here his name was [ __ ] loose
Desi Arnaz Desi Arnaz invented the three
camera shoot did you know that that's
hilarious that does he loop production
to all that [ __ ] that he's the one that
said what has it took eight white people
sitting around
get two more cameras let's go I'm the
light the guy that is the principal guy
in narcos this year is a character who
grew weed in the desert I want you to
think about that I've never been even
thought of before but by doing that I
don't know the science so please Joe
Rogan people don't torture me he
eliminated the male plant to make the
female stronger the only way you could
grow that is in the desert so he found
water in the desert
why is it the only we can go at grow in
the desert something about the climate
roof so that it's like the Immaculate
Conception well you get pregnant without
getting pregnant so you eliminate the
male plants or something I do not know
this water and right we have to hide
this information from women so there's
no seeds and the reefer gets stronger
that started in the 80s that's why if
you watch the articles in Mexico it
shows you how that whole thing started
and they were pumping 15 metric tons a
year into the United States of this [ __ ]
so green weed became the Mexican green
weed was what we started smoking I gotta
say that average was maybe 15 then like
the strongest and then there's weeds now
that I bother that 21% like they take me
to the [ __ ] mountain but that 28 or
above and a bong you're doomed yeah
you're stuttering your mum when you're
[ __ ] can't focus I like that feeling
at night well I listen to music I love
big news like I want that I called you
like there was like October 3rd and I
was gonna call you to tell you that I'd
love to participate it's sober sober but
because of my love for music it's not
gonna happen because my thing is to go
home and matter sometimes I go to the
office like I told you that my house is
dead at 20 tonight the kid goes to bed
and [ __ ] hate 30 and my wife's in bed
ten minutes later so some nights I don't
have a spot on a podcast I just go to my
office I bring a notebook on an iPad
might get stoned
and I put a little album on I go down
album road I just get [ __ ] up
and listen to that music I love it your
oh that's my hobby and once a week I go
to the album store and I buy in a while
a new vinyl album lately I went now that
leads up one to Road that's one of the
greatest dirtiest filthiest albums and
it opens up with a whole lot of love
it's just dirty then a lemon song and
then a heartbreaker it's just dirty damn
and then I've been listening to [ __ ]
Physical Graffiti I love going into
those foxholes way that night stoned to
the gills yeah there's something about
that music they they were the first drug
culture music in America right if you
think about it except Lynne and pink
floral showed up the Tweedles and they
went the idea they grew longhand that
came back with those four albums then
there was rumors of acid if you listen
to the you know one revoir think it's
revolved one of those John Lennon
spreads acid bond then I mean there's so
there's a lot of musicians from that era
that are great that aren't associated
with drugs but if you think of Hendrix
if you think of I mean Hendrix was
always associated with drugs like Janis
Joplin always associated with drugs you
know good or bad it's it's very
interesting it's very interesting that
the sound is so it lasts like it's so
relevant if you listen to some Zeppelin
today it's still so goddamn good they
were so good so good they were so good I
saw one Zeppelin's tool called bring it
on home at the end he comes out like
with a harmonica slow then Jimmy Page
kicked some one thing at all y'all that
stops yeah like you're arts the house
thank you like I'd she'd why jump out a
window while you Led Zeppelin - there's
a couple of hours I got in that office
that I put on such a part of my
childhood like I think about my mom
coming in the room saying yelling lord
I'd [ __ ] devil music
feeling saying waiter by isamu stick-up
all it and how it blasted at [ __ ]
6:00 in the morning
oh the neighbors next door with jehovah
witnesses and he was knocking on my door
you have to please lower your music I
would I never load it lowered it at that
age that officious stereo okay and I
really do not to get components like I
was already hit like I never bought the
album with the 8-track and the cassette
[ __ ] to you I bought an amp and I bought
a cassette deck and I had a turntable
and I would [ __ ] blast it I don't
know where I got the speakers from my
bottom they fell off a truck I love
music loud my my store every time till
this day everytime Led Zeppelin's final
album comes out I'm you know in through
the out door comes on the radio or
something I think my mother banging on
the door freshman year going if I got to
not have this door one more time I'm
throwing that scenario out the window
like 7:00 in the morning I had that full
[ __ ] speed roll enjoying getting
ready to walk up the hill smoking enjoy
I wouldn't smoke at the house not like
that she had no idea we playing album
album sort of record player yeah [ __ ] I
still do it you don't did you have a
good needle remember you would go over
dude's houses they had a special needle
which good a needle I just wasn't got
new needles I had a hoarder online
impressed of a guy who like a [ __ ]
cool-looking needle I still had a have
friend that had a reel-to-reel Jimmy - I
just got this I had a record player at
my house for short Wow
you had a reel-to-reel a friend of mine
had a really real in high school oh my
god
and the sound he bought the speakers and
everything he knew the sound you could
hear like that the musician pulling away
from the microphone so sound was that
good so when he's playing this
reel-to-reel
it's got like a like a projector screen
type deal no he was that sound he had a
room like this and he had a shelf and on
the shelf he had speakers and he had a
real real
have seen ya he was connected and it
will have two or three hours of music on
it so whenever he would have a party he
would just put on the reel reel at that
time that was the threat that it's going
to real really that's right it's going
to real the real that's the loot threat
that's crew that never made it
it then went from it went from albums to
cassettes to [ __ ] CDs so if you put
something through that you would have to
kind of like do it like you were working
in projection room you take yeah it's
from one of them and it works almost
it's is just really large cassette tape
player you put the music on there I
forget how he put the music on that
could you buy music on I think so it
there's a record button on this too it
looks like so you could have recorded
something on there if you had a cable to
to plug it into it yeah I forget how I
know but they make copies the same way
you put your original would be like on
the left in terms of feet you did you
need a copier you couldn't do with this
machine probably but back the same way
people did with VCR copies back in the
early eighties you know oh yeah tape to
tape isn't the same thing how it would
degrade each generation you get porns
for your friend and it was like like
someone threw mud in your eye
he said watch it the [ __ ] is happening
on the screen because it was so many
generations of copied do you remember
when porn was watch like this I don't
remember it but I heard about it and I
remember that movie about the dude from
Hogan's Heroes
that was a he he was on Hogan's Heroes
and after Hogan's Heroes he just went
around making his own homemade porn and
he you know you had one of these kind of
things on the home projector type field
porn came one in those days if you went
to the back of a dirty magazine not
Playboy and not penthouse but anything
else they would actually send you a
projector with three movies for say 1495
there was a low-end projector it
probably gonna work ten times
but at least you got to watch porn and
they send you a reel-to-reel that was so
bad porn was so bad and I still remember
story with me and my friends chipping in
and getting the [ __ ] reel-to-reel
with the thing and plugging it in the
wall and putting sheets on the windows
and it was just horrible horrible bored
white chicks they were flying off the
streets flapjack titties somebody turns
cigarettes off on the chest
and this chick was half on drugs and
Shanna sucked a guy's dick and the most
vivid picture I remember is when she
took the mayonnaise with the bread like
she was something this guy's nicked the
guy's dick had been beat up and she took
mayonnaise Miracle Whip that's why I
never liked Miracle Whip she put it on
the bread and made a dick sandwiches
with his dick and it was like me and
three other 12 year olds dog we almost
had a heart attack
you understand me like our heads blew up
I turn off crying laughter laughter who
wants this [ __ ] projector no no no no
no no no no no how was a cheap cheap
cheap little projector you had to put a
sheet up on the wall and use it as a
screen you had a [ __ ] shade up all
your windows in the attic because I used
to do it in my attic as my mother wasn't
home so our that the first viewing party
we had was in my attic you had to send
the money on and Janna said the dollar
might 95 for shipping and handling S&H
and then it would take six weeks to the
delivery so you would just sit and you
couldn't send it to your house so I
would have to send it to Rogen's house
because I knew his mother and his
grandmother worked all day so they'd
never be home so they would just drop
the package off in front of the house if
one of our mothers found that package
we'd be dead we'd be [ __ ] dead can
you imagine your mother putting it on
and all suns and checkmate with merit
upon a piece of bread and eats into the
[ __ ] your dick what you think mom's
today probably wouldn't even flinch what
if what if they found their kid with
some
like that on his computer [ __ ]
kidding me every mom the Edit you talk
to any mom fifteen year old and go do
you think your son's getting lazy thing
stopping I don't want to hear that it's
true
no mom wants to hear this I'm getting
laid the first girl you brought over the
house actually bothered your mother oh
I'm sure the first two girls you brought
home actually bothered and irritated the
[ __ ] out of your mother it took your mom
a while because you're always gonna be
that little boy I can't imagine getting
this dick sucked or he just I just put
diapers on ten years ago you know what
else they were worried about they were
worried about you get so many pregnant
because you're so stupid when you're
fifteen sixteen seventeen you guys are
just doing stupid [ __ ] you know you
don't really know how to pull out that
good how good are you at that not very
good you know when you were that young I
mean it's your parents are worried about
you doing something dumb your parents
are worried about you getting pregnant
but they also don't want you having sex
I had this skinny girlfriend like I
always had girls that were friends and
naturally grows would leave my mom would
pull me aside and said what's going on I
know nothing you know she's just a
friend
and I would stream out of the house I
can't believe it you know and there were
friends but there was this one skinny
girl that I used to bring home in the
seventh grade and my mother caught us
one afternoon look like she caught us
making out so she asked me as a man she
was from now on do me a [ __ ] favor if
she's here and I'm downstairs just leave
the door oh my mom was one of those dog
she was alone just do me a favor
just for me it'll mean something when we
lock the door but if I'm here and just
leave the door open and I would leave it
open the foot and then try this eight
inch it six inch it and she would have
to come up and say I was I'm 21 I
thought you leave the [ __ ] door open
and then you you're an animal at that
age said that age you finally talking
with dilemma because all I was doing was
dry humping this girl that's all I was
doing we weren't having sex I think I
sucked at its one time you know we
weren't having sex we just make it out
dry
but one day I had up my mom had the
Barstow and she was just [ __ ] come
home and he afternoon was to see if I
was at this broad and one dad in here
and she brought one our friends up me
one of our friends with her and I'm in
there just swapping spit with the chick
but I hear something on the wall
something's going on but I kept dry hump
but we had her twin in fire this is an I
love great [ __ ] I'm off that's the
way of the world I'm dry-humping this
chick to death and also there here a
ladder slip and the guy starts yelling
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
and I ran downstairs there was one of my
mother's friends I know I know
he used to be a bookie at my mother's
ball so my mother goes I gotta get to
the bottom of this I don't know it's
just kids get laid so he volunteers but
the ladder at the side of the house to
see if I'm getting laid - look at the
width oh my god I had an air conditioner
with a curtain he could never see in any
way but this girl pissed off my mom
fears this one on for about a year and
then I started taking his shirt off and
sucking intense and my dad came home one
main corner in the closet and that was
the end and then my mom would give me
[ __ ] for a little while I gotta be 12 13
I'm in the sixth grade me and this girl
would watch the Osmonds on Friday and
Saturday
Donny and Marie and I would get pissed
off cause she had a crush on I'm [ __ ]
Donny you know you know your kids and
then one day and but then we figured out
[ __ ] if they're gonna watch this after
three why don't we play hooky from 12:00
to 3:00 we could dry out for three hours
and nobody'll know your grandmother
works
my mother's definitely not come along so
we used to play hooky and one day they
caught us and her and I had like there
was 20 feet between us on a fence their
parents had a house right behind mine
and my mom went into the backyard like
the [ __ ] Spanish woman that she is
and started yelling your daughter's a
[ __ ] Oh over here everyday I don't know
what they do in that room I hope she's
not something his dick oh my god it was
just my son was a regular little boy
until you'd thought it took over and I
never I used to walk her home and I'm a
walk in the house the moms like I don't
eat for a second your mom's out there
yelling horrible things about my
daughter calling her a [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow I
had to go home and tell my mama what's
up with that she's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
for the job my mom critized woman drove
my and that's why I got a girlfriend
Linda no more problems after that it was
just the skinny chick that drove my
mother [ __ ] crazy hey they made you
mad I mean imagine you have a little boy
and you take him to the park and he's a
cute little fella and he runs he
stumbles and falls down he cries and you
pick him up and he hugs you and you love
him
you're like it's okay just scrape your
knees okay and he's crying and crying
you feel so bad you feel so bad you get
him a band-aid thinking my kiss and talk
to him and hang out with him then he
goes to sleep and you sit there and you
look at him sleeping you think about how
precious he is this little life for me
yeah you're entrusted with you 15 years
later someone sucking his dick some
dirty little girl down the block
god damn it look at that now he's all I
endure all the time and obsessed with
her it's driving you nuts
how's your baby your baby stuck with
some [ __ ] dirty little [ __ ] media will
I have daughters you will have daughters
which is uh that's a hell on earth
having a daughter is hell on earth it's
fun now it's huge she puts costumes and
she loves daddy she watches TV but
there's an accommodation once more
friends you have to letter you have to
worry yeah and it's not the same world
you know the world is not the same now
it's not gonna be the same when they're
older it's getting weirder and weirder
you know people are getting you know
we're talking earlier about bugs and
searches and people via and we'll turn
your microphones on it has a matter of
time before there's no privacy whether
it's fifty years whether it's a hundred
years and I mean I think there's gonna
be no privacy with anything I don't
think with your thoughts I think we're
gonna this is the next thing after
cellphones is gonna be something that
allows us to communicate way easier
there's gonna within the next 50 years
they're gonna come up with some way
where we're gonna be able all
communicate through a device it's gonna
be better than just talking we're gonna
we're gonna share thoughts it's gonna
get really [ __ ] strange I'm a hundred
percent convinced I think all this stuff
is just getting everything accelerates
right it used to be really hard to get a
hold of somebody now it's really easy to
get a hold of somebody and now your your
connect people have figured out ways to
turn people's microphones on and record
them and people who's putting tape over
there their webcam I want to play look
at while I'm jerking off
okay think someone's gonna look through
it from the other side they probably can
it's gonna be a matter of time before
everybody can with everybody with
everything you do it's gonna be there's
gonna be all all information available
to everybody this is gonna happen we're
so far away from where we were in the
70s so far away so far away so far away
and that was our lifetime we can
remember the 70s you know 1973 I was 6
years old ok I remember that I remember
I remember the Vietnam War I remember
when the war ended thinking when I was a
little kid this is great that the war is
over cuz now they know that war is bad
and they won't do any war anymore the
war is over it's gone and then when the
war started up again when I was I think
I was 21 when Desert Storm kicked in I
was a holy [ __ ] they're doing it again
me and my friend jimmy detillo
we had an apartment in i think it was
[ __ ] where were we
Malden or some [ __ ] I forget where the
[ __ ] we were wall
that's where we were we're in Walt dam
we had this [ __ ] apartment and we
were sitting there on TV which is
sitting in front of the living room I
don't think we got a couch we're just
sitting there in the living room
watching these [ __ ] missiles flying
through the air and I'll never forget he
goes buddy looks like we're at war I was
like what how though we're both sitting
there going what how the [ __ ]
we're at war I thought we didn't do that
anymore
I remember that I remember that whole
that time when when that was how you got
information from the TV is so far
removed from today today everything that
happens all the time is coming at you a
hundred miles an hour from every
direction there's just too much to do so
you have to control it though you have
to control it you still have to have a
wife you still you know I don't have
facebook on my phone I have my email
account I try to keep Twitter off my
phone when I go on the road the iPad has
no Twitter no Facebook it's too much
it's too much interferes of who we are
and if you haven't caught that by now
you're not catching this you know I'll
open up my Twitter on a Saturday just to
see who's tweeting thinking to myself
what are you doing with your [ __ ]
life that you're tweeting on Friday and
[ __ ] Saturday and Sunday you know it
becomes a little game it's it's a little
game you have to give it a breather you
have to you it's too much news coming at
you from 202 on on your satellite disk
it's you know the other thing is it's
too much news from sports to world news
you got HLN CNN and then ESPN all in the
[ __ ] row it's too fast it's too quick
last week when I was old my buddy as a
cab driver I took six overs on Monday
in New York Tuesday I just want to take
a cab I took my wife to get some real
pizza roma pizza the guy that was making
pizza that was still there when I was a
kid I drove by one day and I don't eat
still in there so we took a [ __ ] cab
on the cab this guy that drove me as a
friend of mine we grew up together since
we were 12 and we were talking I go
that's the fasiq first gas station I
robbed and then he goes remember when we
were 12 we'll walk at home and my
Freddie Prinze got killed
Wow Freddie Prinze had killed himself to
lay in before we didn't find out till
that six o'clock news do you know I'm
saying yeah wait that was the gap
anytime mm-hmm so you got your news and
they even though that was New York it
was the city capital who watch TV in the
morning maybe they mentioned it in the
morning reports out of LA for any
princes in the hospital yeah but you
never saw it no I saw I remember us
being out and them saying Freddie Prinze
died he shot himself last night and I
stole him how cold it was it was January
or February was [ __ ] freezing but we
were walking home we were 12 and what
are we seeing in front of us but a guy
passed out drunk just hammered drunk on
the floor so what I call now let's get
the money out of his pocket you take the
bottle it was like a bottle of Dewar's
or whatever so our plan was to take a
bottle and shake a bum what what's it
called you roll a bum yeah and we put
our hands in his pocket he grabbed one
of us like carry so next thing ought to
be was just started kicking him like we
was to kick the matey two times and we
ran away in a bottle he got up in chases
oh Jesus so we do a short path through
the cemetery so he lost but you you get
all those weird things like that's what
I associated with like Freddie shot
himself at night they must have
mentioned it in the morning I was too
busy on the school and it wasn't
confirmed to the next day
that's how slow Lou was now
you're getting news you let hit with 200
stories in 10 minutes yeah what happened
in France what Trump decided what the
UFC is doing what [ __ ] Penny Marshall
died you get to do this thrown at you
all day and you really can't control it
take your child you've watched these two
young girls grow up do you ever have
days where you take them somewhere
Disney and it's so much information they
got to go back and take a nap yeah what
happens to our stuff so yeah that's
gotta be happening to us well for sure
it's wearing you out and it's a lot of
it is really negative too you know
that's that's another part of problems
what's interesting to people is what's
dangerous and there's not much dangerous
so what's interesting to people becomes
you know being negative being nasty
about something complaining about things
bitching about that starting starting
Twitter fights like people enjoy doing
it they're like they're looking for for
battles you know and I wish there was a
way where people could choose to only
engage online without insulting people
and just trying to get a rise out of
people like a troll free way of
interacting but it's never gonna happen
so you got to kind of accept what it is
you see if you accept what it is you
should be very wary about entering to
anything where 60% of what you're
experiencing is negative anything
anything in life where you're looking at
60% negative you don't have to this is
one you like being informed is one thing
but that's more than just being informed
because how much of that information is
evil valuable to you a lot of is just
getting soaked soaked into these [ __ ]
horrible stories you know I mean I went
down a rabbit hole the other day reading
about this these Scandinavian tourists
that got beheaded in Morocco in the
mountains these girls were hitchhiking
and they went it's [ __ ] horrible it's
horrible horrible stuff man
then I watched a video of it it's
horrible mucho ruined you know I loved
your room
one noble headshot gonna Morocco what
your [ __ ] business
you know girls apparently did this all
over the world you do yeah either you
talk about a guy that [ __ ] went
somewhere tried to convert a tribe you
know they showed up with a [ __ ] Bible
you know yeah
mind your business all right send the
[ __ ] Bible via email and do the best
you can there's some people want to put
themselves in dangerous way they don't
think I [ __ ] hate or I'd [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate all that [ __ ] I like
control in my situation I really do I'll
I don't want to sound shallow I would
love to be able to have a passport and
go to China and go to Italy but I'm not
going nowhere whether there's nothing
[ __ ] crazy going on I don't need that
in my life right I don't want to hear a
bomb when I'm [ __ ] sleeping with
Israel talk to Harmony earth day you get
Bob's going chuckling Harvey's like
telling me jokes on the phone yeah and
you hear a bomb going off and [ __ ] I
don't need that I don't need none of
that [ __ ] that's putting yourself in
harm's way you know I appreciate the
balls I appreciate them walls of you
climb the mountain of Jarrow I
appreciate all that stuff but it's not
in my percentage graph I believe in
percentages you understand me I get it
so it's just the the other night I read
so I get high at night guys I could I do
family and to come down I smoked 55
[ __ ] bong hits sometimes you don't
have to say a joke on Twitter
the joke is written when you read it as
a human being you're saying this is a
very interesting article but at the same
time it does I fell immense of humor in
it there's an article of a hot chick and
it says mother goes to court to complain
about teacher who [ __ ] a 15 year old
kid because his life is changed has
never been the same since she [ __ ] me
sure it has it the kids never gonna get
his dick sucked like that again can you
imagine getting a teacher to blow your
horn when you're in high school one of
those dirty teeth you see a picture of
the Joe Rogan with a fish
on a boat with a bikini now you take
this chick to the prom and she's sucking
your dick cryin you know the saying like
I've never done this before you never
saying like we're luck that his life has
changed yeah it's a joke dog I got
attacked for two days and I didn't
reenact people I turned it around on
them I called them love listen Merry
Christmas and they had nowhere to go
it's so funny that you can get caught
man they forget what comedians we are a
tube a tube that transports something
really ugly into something that's still
ugly but a little bit of funny to it
yeah I cracked a joke when I found my
mother dead on the floor to myself which
said I knew she was never gonna know I
got left back cuz I got left back but I
never told and it was couple of a year
that I had to tell her she was she kept
asking me have you chosen to college yet
and then the sophomore year for three
years I ran the scan with my mother that
I had I didn't tell her she thought I
was a Judy I was really a sophomore so
as soon as I made that turn I picked her
up I saw her arm was purple I've kissed
the forehead but I loved the popping up
and going I knew this [ __ ] wasn't gonna
have a phone that I smacked before i
down 9-1-1 so if I dropped humor at that
situation that's how I [ __ ] handle
myself well that's how you leave that's
right yeah you have to drop you but I
will drop a bomb on you at a Funeral
I will drop a bomb on your the feel I
love that you look at me and go Jodie is
the balls on you but thank God you came
they ever tell you what Dave always said
when Phil Hartman didn't win an Emmy
what we were all in the audience right
went there to honor him cuz he got
nominated and the dude from Frasier won
and Dave for which he turns to me and
Steven Rudy goes what the hell do you
have to do to win
[Laughter]
because he got shot for [ __ ] sake
always a funny way [ __ ] really is people
have no idea what I see people argue and
now like now is a 55 year old you look
at it and you go I threw away 20 years
of my life are you with people yeah that
I had no reason to argue with them for
it's not even worth it they played the
tape back you'd laugh at yourself and
feel horrible
hmm you look at [ __ ] now you know what
it how does this even affect your life I
turn it I watch so CN n like when you're
in a hotel room on the weekends you know
you got it you go down to CNN or CH NBC
a political pipe hole oh I love those
four six minutes to see people get fired
up and they attack each other and then
you know and everybody's [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you sit there you know what is the
big [ __ ] deal no matter if [ __ ]
Hitler makes a comeback and he's
president y'all got to get up and go to
work every morning hmm it's like
Thanksgiving your money anymore
something like somebody's giving you
money or their point you in the house
for free if the Dow resurfaces from the
grave he's the president you still gotta
work you still gotta build houses you
still gotta announce the other to the
UFC's you still feel what what it how
much does it really affect yet at least
that's how I've always thought the
problem with all these shows is all of
them whether it's CNN or Fox News or is
that they're leaning they're leaning
somewhere the leaning one they're
telling you about the news but they're
leaning on it in a way they're not just
simply recording this the fact
especially Fox News right they lean like
I don't know right I don't know what you
guys are talking about when you say that
but I will tell you really yeah when
people talk to me about left and right I
have no idea because I don't even know
where I stand on most vicious but guess
what I did see in New York
what take a guess of what I did not see
homeless people really they because it's
so cold I was homeless for 719 days in
New York in December from December 12th
to the 31st I got a hotel room maybe 50%
of the time but beside that I was
homeless at one time in 1984 you did and
I asked people you know you just don't
say it hmm I saw very small sections of
non encampments but the homeless
pizzette percentage was smaller so I
asked somebody what that is how come I
have somebody homeless people out here
and they said it's called because
they're liberals I didn't [ __ ] know
that's what a liberal was I know I did I
just need California's yeah I just try
to be a human being
I don't know that doesn't make sense
it's like what does that mean then what
were you where the homeless go do we
make more of them out here is that what
he's saying
do you allow it the dead philosophy he
was telling me a las vegas ships they're
homeless gives them a bus to California
and my ship I feel like the shipping of
busting people like Alaska for a little
while or something maybe yeah you saw
that the TV show wild wild country do
you see that no it's on the rag Nisha's
I they say it rag neish cult from Oregon
and one of the things they did - they
took over the town all watched it
homeless people in buses and then how
all those people vote and then they took
over the [ __ ] town they like
developed a real town and then they took
over this one area
bust out how America moves its homeless
as well each year US city gives
thousands of homeless people one-way bus
tickets out of town an 18 month
nationwide investigation but the
Guardian reveals for the first time what
really happens at journey's end whoa
that sounds like a M night Shyamalan
movie all right they kill a bunch of
homeless people like Satan's involved
it's like they just move them away where
do they say where they ship them looks
like this throwing up down in Miami and
in LA huh well lives in Colorado in
Colorado people would the homeless
people would commit crimes
they figured out what crimes they would
get 60 days for and they would commit
that crime plead guilty do the 60 days
just figure out a little winter hmm
because in those days
boldwood give you tobacco you were a lot
they would give you tobacco but you
gotta roll it that well that type of
[ __ ] Boulder County Jail and 1991
Boulder County Jail and some other jail
will voted number one in two jails in
the country Wow that people would want
to go to those jails then bold to built
a new jail and it became [ __ ]
communist land like Aspen communist land
yeah like no cigarettes
everybody had awake uniforms huh no more
stayin up till 2:00 in the morning when
I was wrong with the other way Boulder
County Jail the way what was good the
good way up old it was a paradise well
what was wrong with that it got out it
got out that it was too nice right so
like I'm telling you homeless people
would commit a crime to do 60 days can I
ask you something guys as a person who's
been in jail good would it motivate you
more this is an honest question would it
motivate you more if you were in jail
and it was nice and comfortable in there
and you got to relax and calm down or
would it motivate you more if they
brought you into some communist type
jail as you described it with everybody
had wear uniforms there was no
cigarettes there was no fun they limited
your outside time what I did I did them
both what would what I didn't think as a
person who's been through what would be
most effective in rehabilitating you I
mean that's the idea right I don't live
in rehabilitation
now you said to me you gotta stay in
this [ __ ] building for six months
this is gonna be a jail
there's like pablo escobar's jail it's
still jail I want you to remember that
right you cannot leave the building for
six months I will let you go out to her
front and a cage one hour a day but you
got to figure out what you're gonna do
in here for 12 months it's a cage yes I
have more options here I can lift
weights I can do different parts of my
body I could shoot pool ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
Boulder was very simple boldly got
locked up they gave you the linens you
either took them away in it not only in
my own cause so you called home at once
time Joe Rogan's brought me my jeans my
snake is my t-shirts I'm wearing my own
clothes so now they determine what you
were in for nonviolent or violent if
you're a non-violent offender you the
world is yours the violent ones the ones
that get violent ones
so now the violent offenders depending
on what you do as violent you go into
one sector and that sector the longer
you're in there the more rewards you get
so if you're in green you stay up till
tenth and they got cable TV if you are
red you stepped 11 and they got cable TV
if you're purple estep till 1:00 1:00
a.m. oh my god Boulder County Jail was
tremendous I am sweaty so I'm cigarette
I didn't drink milk milk is big in jail
because the bodybuilders like milk it's
like [ __ ] drugs yeah so I would trade
you and you my milk for your kool-aid
all right so I was in there drinking
[ __ ] cool laser [ __ ] because I
[ __ ] hate bill Boulder was a paradise
compared to other jails oh listen to
this
Thanksgiving Day when I was locked up
thanks everyday yeah the guard came in
and I'll never forget his name was
Grande and he opened up the cell door
there was a phone there and he does
anybody who needs to use the phone
use the phone I figured how you know
those days you had a press mind
sideline I press paid to see if I get
along this is London press seven nothing
six not been five nothing for [ __ ]
long business I got the quoi my peeps in
Jersey for 20 minutes of peace you know
you just figure out different things
then they send you to a place where
somebody looks you in the eye and says
strip down and you gotta go take a
shower then you come out and they put a
finger up your ass deceive me that's
contraband and they give your tighty
whities an orange jelly put like a
rubber glove on and then lube their
finger up it doesn't matter it does at
that point I didn't give a [ __ ] you're
putting the finger up my ass
is it it breaks you down as a man as
much as anything in the world that's the
first breakdown Wow they turn you around
to let you know they run you they're
gonna stick it up your ass then you
order yourself and like those guys are
then are not very nice they weren't like
the Boulder County Jail guys those guys
would kick your bed and make you get up
turn your light on in the middle of
night and say get out of bed we're gonna
do a search at 2:00 in the morning those
people are not nice at all then I got
transferred the summer County Jail which
was a [ __ ] paradise paradise paradise
handball all day outside TV till 2:00 in
the morning keep easing yourself
black-and-white TVs and yourself
basic cable you could be up all night if
you wanted to go to breakfast you ate
breakfast if not you could sleep through
breakfast and we'd eat your breakfast
for you and then from there they shipped
me off the Department of Corrections
that's where it's a nitty gritty if you
think black people talking to movie
theater at night don't go there
[Music]
don't go that black people talk all
night it's six or seven floors and I was
in there in August with feel full
humidity Canyon City Colorado Wow
alright with a little window you know
and I was like on the third floor I
couldn't breathe and in those days they
let you out you think two showers a week
and one hour a day you went outside
after that you were just in the cell by
yourself and then nighta froze the
daytime it was like [ __ ] being
sweating in a [ __ ] tin can you wanna
ten candidates on it now we're finished
nope it's all [ __ ] there's nothing to
showers and then the three meals and
then that then the first week is good
because you actually get out of your
cell ago test they test you everything
your math your English they [ __ ] put
a bunch of pictures of funny and they
put you through psychiatry they take
your blood out they do everything and
then they assess you and then they have
I took care of all the dots okay there's
a bunch of dots you have to you have to
dot your i's like if you have a high
school diploma you get a point if you
were working at the time of arrest you
get a point if you up to paying rent so
I got a bunch of points for that it's so
funny out to talk about something very
interesting it's very interesting
whether it's Harvey Weinstein case is
gonna go it's very interesting where
it's gonna go
right now he has Benjamin Braff as an
eternity and if you see what happened
Benjamin Bratt push for a dismissal and
he didn't get it the lawyers said the
judge set a trial date they gotta get a
trial date Harvey Weinstein's gonna go
throw more money to pay off time
Harvey's gonna go for time then he's
gonna fire a Benjamin breath
and show up with two women primarily one
black and one Asian or one white and one
Asian and this is when this trials and
they get very interesting
Harvey's also really hire millions of
dollars and prosecuted in a private
investigators they don't interview
boyfriends they can interview this case
is gonna be very interesting
unlike the Cosby case where Cosby didn't
really [ __ ] you how do you know he's
gonna do all the stuff because I know of
this is what I would do I know if you
come to me and you know I'm getting
busted for this what do I do because of
how I grew up around those people this
is what you do Benjamin Braff cannot ask
a woman the same question and a woman
can ask a woman hmm
so I'm gonna go in there with either a
black woman but the Asian woman or a
white woman my first two choices are
black and an Asian woman you want to get
the diversity angle I'll get the
diversity angle and I want to get that
you can't you're saying that cuz you're
a black woman Chinese woman what I'm
trying to stem you have just did you
ever really watch the People vs OJ
Simpson no I didn't very interesting and
it's it's time that you sat next version
I watched one episode it seemed very
good very interesting how you put a
dream team together how Jesus it's gonna
cost you ten mil listen to me gee you
got two hours he's going on like Cosby
and pay two mil and make believe you're
blind or we put together a [ __ ] you
didn't you see him he went no with that
milky [ __ ] over his eyes like the guy
from kung fu when we were kids kung Fu's
father head like yeah kung fu father was
like half blind and [ __ ] yeah I remember
each other's eyes that's how Cosby will
in there playing like I'm sick routine
he's got cataracts whoo
Cosby yeah but he didn't have like that
that when he put the pill in the water
either no he knows what he knows with
the [ __ ] so Larry steps really
[ __ ] you know yeah he knows but
Harvey has to play this hand this is
what America's about to watch they're
gonna watch something [ __ ] crazy
Harvey knows he can't go in there
Benjamin Bratt Benjamin Bratt hey
Gravano look at the list of Benjamin
Perez and Benjamin Bratt can't attack a
woman Joey you look at love like legal
cases like supports Dalek is debilities
Jon Jones versus Gustafson I went to New
York last week and I went to the
Metropolitan Museum of Art with my
daughter she loves art and while I was
sitting there I was at it saying I'm
going on your own cuz my daughter didn't
want me taking pictures in front of the
statues anyway she said daddy get out of
the pictures this - so I'm like what the
[ __ ] am i hanging out with you for she
was in the Chinese when I wanted to see
the Armenian way but it was funny I was
thinking about when I was 21 and 22
jor-el and I would get stoned to the
gills and go to the Museum of Natural
History the Museum of my hobbies back
then since I was such a loner people
looking for me I was always a criminal I
would go over the bridge to either go to
one of those museums
I would sit in the courtroom I would go
to a place that had a [ __ ] Italian
sandwich and I got a bag of wise potato
chips in the 16mm scope and you go to
any courtroom
court starts at 7:00 at the metropolitan
downtown I take the A train and I'd walk
I forget now what you know this is 1983
81 I was a kid and I would sit
unobserved Night Court I learned how to
plus I grew up in that you were what
you'd sit and watch Night Court look
you'd watch a basketball game with your
games yeah with a sandwich
and the soda and potato chips I think a
lot of people don't realize you can just
go to court and I would watch you do
that 12 people I would learn how to set
bail can you do that anytime you want
can you just get in there watch in the
80s yes now this bomb detectors you have
that's the reason why you're there do
you have to but if you're interested in
the case yeah good night in just watch
it but if you you know for whatever
reason there's a speeding thing like
someone lost their license and they got
arrested driving you're gonna get away
from cops you go watch them go go
supporting Joe I like to go and I see I
would like to see what the [ __ ] was
going on when those guys are trying to
get away from the cops the helicopters
chasing them with the spotlights and
they just keep going like what the [ __ ]
were you thinking like what I would like
to get to that courtroom here I want to
see that guy I want to look at that guy
that was like running from the cops the
[ __ ] spotlight from the helicopter on
me knew he wasn't gonna get away he's
gotten people off and driving in the
[ __ ] side it'll nobody ever gets away
has anybody ever gotten away recently
the other night a parking garage I can
find them oh yeah take it away the
percentage is explained all right the
percentages are very [ __ ] low right
it's tough to get away bro they got you
once those helicopter spotty you running
through neighborhoods to a mall they
have cameras they can rewind the cameras
watch you go if you're running into the
mall you know there he is
well spot on the car the thug hey big
what happens to you you wanna know what
happened to see what happens to all
right first of all usually spike skyline
is following you so that's the news yeah
they gotta put you on the floor kick
your legs do everything by procedure on
camera then they pick you up they
handcuff you and they put you to the
side of the car the guy tells you this
whole white version of what happened the
pursuit started on the vibe this wanted
subject yes suspect was moving at a high
rate of speed [ __ ] you know if I just
had to chase you for 20 miles I'll piss
to my you oh yeah so they put you in the
[ __ ] trunk and they push in the back
seat in front of everybody so the
cameras take places
they put a cop next to you on the drive
day you got a couple back hands to your
face because I'm saying that you you hit
the steering wheel or something a couple
times then you go in there and you sit
in the holding tank and then you [ __ ]
if you're with one another person used
to you just shut your [ __ ] mouth you
want to call your lawyer I'll call them
whether you wanna call your lawyer
because you want one of the other guys
to get a lawyer so then like that you
have to get ah it's it's puppets
it's conflict of interest so if me you
and Jamie get arrested right now I'm
gonna shut my mouth and tell you I'm
gonna call my attorney later because I
know for a fact Jamie's only got a
public defender so now I can't get a
public defender because well that's
conflict of interest so the state has to
pay for a different attorney for me well
a lot of people don't know that so if
you got arrested with two or three
people you keep you much yeah I'll call
my attorney later you have an attorney
yeah I forget his name let Jamie cop a
public defender now the two public
defenders can't represent you
haha you got a better chance of getting
a better attorney and the state pays for
it it's on the young so next time you
pay for your Morgan's you know goddamn
at the state takes aside it's cuz they
jerk off like me when we [ __ ] Johnny
run but abouts and [ __ ] him he wants
eight hundred an hour even though the
state will give before hundred now it's
like wholesale am saying by at least I
got a better type of attorney you game
the system you game the system it really
is [ __ ] crazy how I love figuring
this [ __ ] out you write you're writing
things down like you weren't even
thinking you just automatically started
writing down numbers and percentages
[ __ ] oh yeah I love all this I grew up
in this [ __ ] it is like a sport so
that's what he'll do hot and by the time
ha we bring on a rape case you gotta go
up there we lived the story and tell the
dates and if there was a rape kit it's
very [ __ ] tough this is gonna be very
interesting bro what's gonna happen
the only thing is anything he cops to
he's gonna come they gonna come back I
don't like OJ hmm and try this also and
he'll just live in Florida making
[ __ ] super 8 films dad I've been
[ __ ] in Miramar Florida is crazy we
can't get sued because they work the
system I'm not saying nothing bad here
that's what your advisors and your
people run you know tell you he's in hot
water for the rest of his life because
even if he gets that down to like an
assault charge and he has to serve eight
months 12 months which is really eight
once he gets out hey all the civil suits
are gonna come at him and then he has to
pull a little gem move to Florida where
they can't touch your pension or some
[ __ ] money and into something like
that Wow it's really crazy this is not
unrelated to what we're talking about
right now so this has happened I think
since we've been live Kevin Spacey
uploaded this video on his YouTube
channel where he's in character as Frank
Underwood and since this has come out
today he's now been indicted on rape
charges and Matt Massachusetts I believe
whoa felony rape charge so it's his plea
to get his job back this might have come
out without him knowing that was gonna
happen I don't know I was to see if you
wanted to watch and see what he's doing
should we watch it if we watch we're
gonna kick some YouTube news it's fair
use ish ish I mean it should be
definitely fair use we can always watch
a minute or two something like there are
a second seven see what he's doing he's
washing his hands
I know what you want oh sure they may
have tried to separate us but what we
have is too strong is too powerful I
mean after all we shared everything you
and I I told you my deepest darkest
secrets I showed you exactly what people
are capable of I shocked you with my
honesty but mostly I challenged you and
made you think and you trusted me even
though you knew you shouldn't so we're
not done no matter what anyone says and
besides I know what you want you want
him back of course some believed
everything and I've just been waiting
with bated breath to him he confessed it
all they're just dying to have me
declare that everything said is true and
that I got what I deserved
wouldn't it be easy if it was all so
simple only you and I both know it's
never that simple not in politics and
not in life but you wouldn't believe the
worst we see Karen Karen yes that's
supposed to be dead in the show correct
that's strange to watch coz but wait you
know what strange is it seems a little
off his game right I mean I don't know
if he's playing Frank Underwood yeah he
seems a little off like okay with a
little tense on that one let's uh oh
yeah let's get into this
you're Frank Underwood come on man Kevin
you're Frank under it I'm Frank
Underwood and then boom hit it a second
time there's a second take felt smoother
second take felt smoother you know it
seems like acting it's weird it's not
like it's great character but that
character's [ __ ] great character I
mean the Frank Underwood characters like
one of the all-time TV characters but
that's just weird he's brought him in
the real life for statutory fox news
according to Fox News but this is what
everywhere else too
he shared this video as he's announced
that he's facing felony sexual
starts at salt charges for assaulting a
teenage son of a former news anchor and
then Nantucket bar in 2060 Jesus thought
he was going off on that powder oh and
God knows the power they give you and
what you buy in so just to make that
tape just shows you how [ __ ] creepy
he's good
I really think to be that good at acting
you gotta be out of your [ __ ] mind
Kevin Spacey's a bad [ __ ] when
it comes to acting all the horrible
things he's done aside there's a there's
a quality about someone that's that good
you know they're just got a like a
certain amount of insanity - god this is
not apologizing for his actions
everything he did is horrendous but I
mean to be surprised that you're seeing
him seem crazy there no that's not
surprising he's - he's too good to not
be crazy like I would assume that
they're all when they're not crazy I'm
shocked you know when someone there's a
you know seems to like Daniel day-lewis
doesn't seem to be crazy right he just
seems to be obsessed it seems to be
obsessed with work maybe I'm wrong
I think all those brilliant
[ __ ] are out of their mind says
his out of his mind as if every jump was
a horrible I did when I was a kid my
grandparents did certainly Shep is a
very smart intelligent oh yeah but they
all have a quirk they all have a core
you know my mom wouldn't neuter us if
she had a female bleed once a month
which made him even [ __ ] crazy so now
as a kid my mom had one that you can go
to next to a purse that buddy's stinky
had one my buddy stinking had a German
Shepherd that was pure authentic
he's a walk in the house I have a great
time I'd a to make a move for the door
so he bid all our friends in the ass
didn't like when people laughed everyone
so every one of us because of the
extreme of what we do including yourself
has to have some you know something you
will I wanted to felt less we speaking
about Bill
he wanted a helicopter he plays the
drums yeah he's a comedian he's a dad he
doesn't animated series you know you
know so here you are the helicopter with
bill burr flying around the city but two
nights earlier he you laughing him
onstage right he made funny some [ __ ] in
that when I saw him last he was
hysterical make him follow you Obama
tour yeah you know so you follow me yeah
those extremities is what makes you good
at your main thing you know the fact
that that [ __ ] does all those
different things the fact that cowboy
Cerrone fights at a high level of
competition but then two weeks later
he's high diving off a cliff for
motorcycle racing not just dad he does
it Wow yeah that's raining while he's in
training yeah that's what makes people
who the [ __ ] they are yeah you know way
when it comes to drugs psychedelics or
the hard [ __ ] you know you get these
people that for years I heard rumors
about certain actors that they show up
on this set still coked up from the
night before but give me three cups of
coffee give them breakfast um take a
shower and then whoever they're supposed
to be so for that love eight hours they
kept it together for the other twenty
they were a [ __ ] mess Wow look at
guys like Nick Nolte right Nick Nolte is
one of the greats for sure right I mean
unbelievable actor and it's had some
serious serious substance abuse issues
and it's passed Jan Michael Vincent
after taking over Hollywood watch the
mechanic you know yeah
we have listen bro dimitru movement was
a great movement it made people you know
whatever the word still had people
always count but what do you think
happened to Marilyn Monroe she was the
first meet through victim Marilyn Monroe
was if you look at it from an angle they
passed her around
between the president Nick Buoniconti
the [ __ ] mobster in Chicago and who
else passed her around she was married
to Mickey Mantle she was married how
many [ __ ] times
she's my tool a right take tormented
that poor girl then they found her were
dead alcohol whatever no no no to me
Marilyn Monroe will I see Marilyn Monroe
she's the first thought an original me
to you know that they're knocking down
all of gardener and Schrader on Sunset
Boulevard but the last but everything is
closed the nerdmelt disclosed everything
is closed on that block the only thing
that's still open is that flower shop
they finally decided to close after a
thousand years but that was the flower
shop where if you wanted to take Marilyn
Monroe impress her you gotta order
flowers from that flower shop that was
what it was famous for that DiMaggio
Sinatra everybody ordered flowers for
her for that shop if you knew her they'd
say what is she like get flowers from
that place on Sunset but she was the
original come on dog think about how
tragic her life was and she was
beautiful she was young and I had them
all but all of a sudden a slick young
guy comes along with his olive oil voice
and his tight shoes and he takes her
away from me I'm a man that cannot hit
be humility and isn't that what that
dude tells walks this now what he tells
Robert Duvall when he comes over in 2000
he wants an outfit in the movie yeah and
he goes there's a piece ass and I've had
them all and she was the best piece AB
just to show you it's not about dollars
and cents
I put singing lessons into dancing
lessons she was gonna be a [ __ ] star
but all of a sudden your boy comes along
with his olive oil voice and his shiny
shoes and he makes me takes her away
from me I'm not a man to be humiliated
you know what that felt like and he goes
off on me through
[ __ ] what's-his-name how the next
morning he wakes up in the dead horses
that's right that's the speech he gives
that Sinatra [ __ ] took his girl that's
right the horse and the bed scene was
one of the most [ __ ] up scenes ever in
a movie especially when you attend yeah
cuz if I was a horse's head oh yeah do
they really oh yeah they killed a
[ __ ] horse for that scene a hundred
percent that ain't a [ __ ] rubber
horse that's a real horse's head
you ever watch it again no I don't think
I'm mistaken I'm a pretty sure I
remember this I remember that it was I
might have a [ __ ] man that I think that
they might [ __ ] throw you in jail
today
today even then the 70s you can get away
with it what's that movie twists my butt
Rose made well he was gonna throw the
dog got the plane and the inspector
showed up and they kept saying oh oh
[ __ ] well that's the movie leads to
stuntman and Jan Michael Vincent comes
to take his job
there's an old Burt Reynolds movie
hopper hopper hopper that's a movie
about Burt Reynolds being Bertram the
baddest stuntman of all time but then
Jim Michael shows up and jam Michaels
and he does lunch but then Burt Reynolds
puts jam waggle in his place and they
make the judgment the car together but
the funny thing about that movie is that
he has the jump out of a building and
the guy that played the inspector was a
wacky guy we got here Jam this is uh
Snopes article it's true yeah Oh Canada
horse the studio had encouraged Francis
Ford Coppola to use a fake horse head
but he didn't take he didn't like the
mock-up his Scouts found a horse ready
for slaughter at a dog food plant in New
Jersey
the art director picked one that looked
like the horse in the film and said when
that one is slaughtered sent us the head
he said one day a crate with dry eyes
came with a horse's head in it five hmm
well that sounds like they're gonna kill
the horse anyway that's probably better
than not using it right but people have
attached wheat they serve the horse
rectum once on fear factor and horse
people got real mad they get very mad
this is seen here we go you imagine
being this poor [ __ ] and being in tangle
with the mob back then this is supposed
to be filmed in what like the 50s as
well it's supposed to take place in the
50s I'm not showing it just you know
Yeah right
oh the people at home they can look okay
it's very what's really scary about this
scene is that they came into your house
while you were sleeping they didn't wake
you up yup and they put a horse's head
under a sheet message under your sheets
so I keep realizes there's some blood
now he's looking around he's like what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this how good
is his actor who's his actor what's his
name he's been in everything yeah he's
looking at the blood it's all over his
[ __ ] sheets
I mean it's [ __ ] crate and that's
real blood - and there's a horse's head
they start screaming aha they chopped
his [ __ ] stuff it in bed with him
that was like a prize stallion that he
had right he [ __ ] took him and he and
he insulted he insulted me go see you
can get out and I ain't no bandleader
and he knows yeah I heard about that
story because that was a story Michael
tells to check it that day
how do you know Sinatra she goes well my
father's done all this to him he's his
Godfather I think those what does that
mean and he goes he sang with the Tommy
Dorsey band and Tommy said I'm not
releasing them and they put a gun to his
head
Luca Brasi put a gun to his head
you either gonna sign it or your brains
gonna be across it which one they paid a
dollar for the Sinatra oh my god so
that's why would this guy shows up
because I ain't no [ __ ] bandleader and
that was the last thing you tell some
guy like Robert Duvall Robert Duvall
says if for your mind I have a plane
have you driver sent over a point it's
kept me till the plane cuz Vito Corleone
he's a man of insisting bad news right
away and hearing bad news right away and
he knows you don't tell him and the next
morning he wakes up with a [ __ ] dead
horse Jesus Christ what a way to send
somebody a message so that was a good
[ __ ] movie all those movies were
great I got a guy the problem is that
got Italians way too into being Italian
overemphasizes crazy I will tell you
this Joe wrote and I told you this a
couple weeks ago and I know it's tough
for you it's tough for me subtitles but
this episode of narcos is really a bit
more are they doing it all on subtitles
no they got a little on official on
English but it's tough for people to
watch but like I took the guy who played
Pablo was a bad like I was saying the
other day I was telling somebody you
know what man
I grew up watching American movies and I
loved him but my undercurrent was
watching Spanish television at that from
the age of five to eight of nine there
was a couple novellas that I really
appreciated and I kind of like the
acting I was like these guys can [ __ ]
act but I forgot all about it then I
watched man on fire and Men on fire had
some phenomenal Spanish acting plus they
had the Italian guy Giancarlo Giannini
how bad of a [ __ ] how bad I'm a
[ __ ] Italian at you when your
name is Giancarlo Giannini he's the one
that was in
Hannibal that Hannibal stabs him and
then [ __ ] throws his guts out in the
[ __ ] I don't know if you've ever
watched Hannibal nah he shows up and
that's how Wow he kills them to my
stomach
but he's the cop and man on fire the one
who thinks just a girl's ass
yeah man on fire had a lot of good like
side actors but a lot of great Spanish
acting slow vs. Marcos and all the
hold-down all these shows are coming
back I'm watching these dudes and I'm
like pearl he's tied these guys from old
soap opera Spanish soap operas was just
tough if you ever did a soap opera
it's a time I did General Hospital and
let me tell you something if I would
have gotten off a plane and done General
Hospital I was gotten fired thank God I
was he at twelve and thirteen years and
I knew my way around the set and you
know when you booked a soap opera nobody
talks to you you don't know that yeah
like you walk into CBS ABC over there on
oh god street you walk in they leave
your ID and then go go to room 27 you go
to your office you [ __ ] your suits
they're lost on the lady comes in and
she knows how you doing my name is
Mildred watch the TV and look for your
numbers to come up so you sit down
you're writing numbers I'm insane 27
chapter ace and you sit down with
wardrobe on for you I would go there at
eight o'clock I might be in my car like
all the time really
how many soap operas did you do three
General Hospital three episodes
yeah find that three episodes of General
Hospital I played a recovering [ __ ]
preacher I've been out in prison and I
came out and now I was a [ __ ]
marriage thing bro when they called me I
think they called me they're like we're
interested in you sending your real and
I'm like wait so Benjamin Bratt those
good-looking dudes they start on General
Hospital and you want me on your loss
are you [ __ ] crazy
I sent them a real I swear to god Wayne
just like they really want
show me will you want me to do me no
send it all what do you want me to
deliver gonna hire me bro they called
right back
come on down for three days Wow
you walk in there Joe Rogan you give him
your ID it's that fast you go to your
room
don't say scene 28 prepare wardrobe
you're ten minutes away you put whatever
wardrobe they give you on they have cue
cards for you they have a yeah under a
[ __ ] under the cameras it's a three
camera shoot you go out it says okay
actor number 28 come out you come out
how you doing Joe Rogan very nice to
meet you okay let's do this action boom
boom boom boom let's say you [ __ ] up
your line they don't give a [ __ ] like if
you start from all over now we're
starting from that line ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba cut moving ahead Wow an awesome
they switch you out bi ba they put
makeup on you and they're like you just
not in the scene just sit over here for
five minutes bro five minutes they come
right back to you alright you ready
it seems to read you like what the [ __ ]
Bob you're right thank you for coming
down nobody talks to you nobody does
nothing huh
so it's not uh it's a they're just
trying to get it out quick
they don't hold your hands it's 8 to 5
Wow Beano is so proper is probably the
easiest way like if you land on general
[ __ ] you could be in a general
husband for 30 is that dudes but I'll
never do it he is yeah you know you to
be on the people been on it for a long
time yeah so it's look it's 8 to 5
General Hospital was that Luke and Laura
it was that was Luke and Laura right
remember Luke and Laura happened there
was a thing that happened in in soap
operas and it happened while I was a kid
Luke and Laura transcended
General Hospital and became a thing all
throughout the world these people yeah
these people he makes sense cuz the
dudes hair was weird and it was a
strange couple I do the scene would have
dog they were weird yeah I didn't sing
with him she was a little too hot for
him didn't make a whole lot of sense but
it worked great for whatever reason it
fire culturally and became a big thing
and I think I was in high school at the
time there were there was the 1983 okay
yeah so I was in high school while I was
in high school this was all going down
and everybody paid attention to Luke and
Laura it was like the General Hospital
thing took over the country it was like
in the cover of People magazine and [ __ ]
it was everywhere it was this one weird
relationship on a soap opera for some
reason just became this gigantic
phenomenon that everybody was watching I
mean I was watching it I would like I
said 30 million viewers crazy I was what
was what was the show with the
good-looking singer I wishes she was
Jesse's girl over a Springfield General
Hospital and I watch that yeah but it
wasn't even him see if him if he was
with Laura I watched I saw that he's a
handsome son of a [ __ ] that Rick
Springfield you know and he was a double
threat he was on General Hospital and he
was a badass singer that Jesse's girl
that song if you read [ __ ] like Wild
Wings and Jesse's girl comes on he's
still out there hitting it still torn
yeah he's still torn I think he was at
the canyon Club in Agoura he's out there
that dude was when I was in high school
that dude was on top of the [ __ ] food
chain every girl at a poster Hill on the
wall my Laketown that's not good for him
it's crazy that whatever soap opera was
on from 12:00 to 1:00 was a big-time
soap opera
and there was a bar in New York and
there was a bar in New Jersey in my
neighborhood and if you walked in there
from 12:00 to 1:00 and you said a word
somebody would tell you to shut the [ __ ]
up and it was 98% men and they would
serve lunch and it was the one I would
go to was the Midtown lounge but there
was another wall so there was a
lunchtime soap opera yes that men left
their jobs full construction guys and
they would sit there watch the soap
opera on two TVs like it was a Yankee
game
what the [ __ ] and then they would go
back to work
I know strain is that how strange is it
that was the thing it was a big thing at
one point and I still remember you know
if you dated a girl and she stayed in on
Wednesdays to watch dynasty [ __ ] you
stayed on dynasty night if that's gonna
get them looking cookie that makes sense
for like today it's translatable you
know Sunday night Game of Thrones is on
or whenever night it's on it's like
people do get together and they watch it
live as it goes on that makes sense what
doesn't make sense is that the market
for those kind of soap operas was there
was appealing to men and high school
kids like we're all watching it who shot
junior bro does Dallas but then yeah not
only were they sucking you in the
daytime in those days this is all the
80s we're talking about the eighties
correct okay what the [ __ ] was going on
at night ball you had Dallas and you had
what was the one on ABC with Alexis
Carrington dynasty and the dynasty that
was badass as a sad-ass [ __ ] that girl
right now the chick who played the
princess on that that was supposed to be
Alexis's daughter and she was having an
affair with Dex Dexter she's the one
right now that's going through that
thing with her daughter in the sex ring
hmm up in Connecticut there was like a
sex ring novo went over right like he's
a princess or your life watches yes
she's the one that's going through all
that with the daughter I remember her
being on dynasty as a hot hot and she
was Alexis's daughter but Dex Dexter was
Alexis's husband and she had something
from Dex Dex Dexter I'm gonna be lame is
that
look at that cast Joan Collins she's
still hot back then she's the original
milf right yeah for sure cuz she was
super hot how old do you think she was
back then fifty yeah she was 51 she was
flushing Dex Dex she's hot as [ __ ] and
look at Ricardo Montalban how much Pete
that dude got paid on that [ __ ]
Island House Island how they haven't
done a remake of fairness he didn't they
did a comic well couple comics went out
there and did it yeah they had it they
had it was on TV for a little bit
no they [ __ ] wasn't The Love Boat yeah
was it cool alive boat am i confusing it
before [ __ ] them no but I mean a new
version of it was there was either a new
version of The Love Boat or new version
of Fantasy Island so one of the two
neither one dynasty actually was but it
was in the 90s it was it was in the 90s
because do you memory cherry-red Wilson
tonight yeah so Jerry read Wilson was
supposed to be filming that what was it
which was about the next will of vote
Jerry Brad Wilson was supposed to be
filming that show and he went to a
doctor and turned out he had meningitis
and I guess apparently he left the
doctor's office cause it was awaiting a
honeymoon and he by time he got there I
guess flying when you have that's really
bad but time he got there he died where
he died shortly after it's horrible
horrible to hear he was a good guy he
was a good guy that funny funny honest
is so you had a lot of [ __ ] character
I worked at that kid a lot in New York
we did gigs together on the road
together a little bit too I was a good
little clique I'm in Bloomington Seattle
he came up louis c.k came up all those
guys were all coming up together at that
time in New York so it was a good bunch
of guys you know you know yeah man they
do remake a lot of [ __ ] television
shows though I mean it is [ __ ]
ridiculous
they were they remake so many shows
makes it like is it that hard to come up
with a new line of thought like how many
more fazham be show is gonna have they
have a new zombie show right I think
they're making World War Z as China but
there's a new Walking Dead in China now
I think okay
Jesus Christ like that I think I know
what's gonna happen bad things you know
like you have when you were growing up I
don't know what the [ __ ] he grew up
let's just say Boston for a while there
was one [ __ ] sandwich shop and he
wanted it all the time a little Italian
guy and then he made you legitimate and
which and all of a sudden another guy
opened up but that was cool but now
subway came and now the Safeway started
making sandwiches so now nobody's making
money it's the same thing with movies
and TV it's like there's so much content
we can't keep up with it
can keep up you can't keep up with the
amount of content that's out there so
when you try to remake the show I want
it to be they remake a ton of [ __ ] but
they forget the main element of it which
is the heart aspect of it let me tell
you something you gotta say that's good
that's out right now on Amazon Prime
marvelous mrs. Mazal tremendous some of
you some mediums you watch it yeah yeah
the two episodes why she's a stand-up
comic and she's hanging out with Lenny
Bruce it's [ __ ] amazing it's a good
cool show it's a real good show it's a
real good show that's the first show
I've ever watched on Amazon Prime it's
very easy to do you just set it up
through the Apple TV with a log and or
bam [ __ ] things it's [ __ ] it's
like but the thing about like things
like Apple TV or Netflix that are so
good is once you're logged in it's right
there right you go to it it's easy
we're so lazy now that the extra step to
log in to another service whether it's
whatever it is you know would another
thing on top of the getting onto iTunes
all right Evan one more thing oh my god
I gotta use my password like that little
extra step even just setting it up once
you get it set up you can just go to it
but before you do that that extra step
bothers the [ __ ] out of people for
whatever reason it's ease oh I just have
my wife programming for me
my iPad you no no no I got to play I
pull into airplane mode I hit the Wi-Fi
thing and that's II know I'm watching
[ __ ] TV I get it I try to keep it's
like I'm work right now I'm on the
second time or watching narcos Mexico
because I like the acting so much that
the guide Diego Luna Joe Rogan ain't no
joke
that dude was a goober my time being
it's such a difference he's such a
badass [ __ ] I don't want to
spoil it for you but [ __ ] you if you
haven't watched it by now you slippin
yeah I only watched the first two
seasons together you watch the Pablo
sees yeah which one he was very good he
was a very good actor I enjoyed him then
the third season with the but the colony
cartel and that was okay this Mexican
one just stood alone one this we're
fully based from when you watch this
[ __ ] explains a lot why Felipe is the
way Felipe is I tell you what if I could
move this in the lower I would I belong
down it's just a city full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy thieves and [ __ ] you know
they just crazy and they figured out how
to grow weed in the desert and they were
making thirty million dollars a week a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] Indians oh we
never found out how much
what percentage of marijuana did we'd
used to have is you're right but it's
also really hard to test back then and
they cross yeah they were testing him
right it's wrong this weed I was smoking
back then with chocolate I weed that
we've made you go [ __ ] crazy someone
to explain to me the difference between
strains that were raised in Afghanistan
and and strains that came from other
places right like right now Dean our
friends from the store he got a seed
from an Afghani weed from the old days
[ __ ]
so here apologized that I guess the word
he uses and he keeps trying to get that
seed but I storm I'm smoking Afghani
weed you were going for rock you were
going for a ride but your your tolerance
is so high now and the weed you're
smoking is weapon-grade I mean you're
you are you are smoked in some of the
most insane weed I hate a bleep
a vape pen the other day a simple little
vape pen I took one hit I was
obliterated you couldn't believe it all
right now yeah
damn strong they are now you gotta be
really careful now I was cocky I was
treating like the old ones especially
those disposable ones you can take 3-4
hits before you even feel it one hit of
alliterated but especially since I
stopped with the edibles that changed
the game Oh me yeah
the edible drop change the game of it
you a hundred percent off the edibles
100 percent oh my god a job a buddy
George has thousand milligram Hannibal's
and he gave me two bags I think like
tonight oh I'll take a bite out of the
edible cause it's Christmas but I had to
cut it out because it was just killing
me it was it was taken away from my
other high I enjoy taking two hits off a
pipe in the morning gets me gone gets me
listening to music I'm writing a little
bit of moose
I love being loose on with the movie
tie-in 9 I had two hits at me and I'm
sorry I enjoy that [ __ ] I can't when I
throw on the road I don't bring a pipe
so I gotta bring joints in me if I gotta
come down off the 11th floor and walk
two blocks I gotta smoke the whole
[ __ ] joint so I gotta go back to my
room and pass out right that's how
strong the way this I can just kills me
especially now I'm not eating them
anymore yeah just kills me mummifies me
I go back to the room I watch two three
episodes or something I think of that
this scientists making weed now
I mean they've gotten they got real
botanists involved there's money in it
now and now that it's opening up in
Canada it's gonna be really weird
because in Canada they're making it
legal right it's legal now so I'm pretty
sure RJ Reynolds is that who wasn't just
dumped a [ __ ] ton of money into some
marijuana production in Canada that's
gonna follow suit the United States it's
there's too much money involved in it
and it's gonna be good for everybody
it's gonna be good for capitalism it's
gonna be good for people getting
marijuana as long as regular people
could sell marijuana to let [ __ ] r.j.
Reynolds as long as they don't put some
restrictions like they were trying to
put was it you Jamie they told me about
what they were trying
in Ohio where they were trying to make
it set up where you could you could grow
weed but only a couple companies could
grow it so the we would be legal but
only a couple companies will monopolize
and then everybody was like [ __ ] this
they but they ended up passing it I
believe that's terrible
it's sad that that mean that's such a
corruption that's like saying okay you
can have Tomatoes but we're the only
ones who grow these [ __ ] Tomatoes
like why it's a tomato that's a law
against nature so you're saying that
nature can't take place I can't put a
seed in the ground and grow my own [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here is it legal
it's legal okay how's it different than
corn how's it different than a [ __ ]
pear tree
it's not it's it's a legal life form
it's a life form it's a plant you're
allowed to grow it if you say you can't
grow it you got a corrupt system you got
some [ __ ] law that you weaseled in
because you greased up some [ __ ] and
the other people don't have as much
money as you do it's the only reason why
that ever happens or people are so
desperate to get legal weed that they
let some [ __ ] dominate the entire
industry some greedy [ __ ] no the the
deal is it's legal or it's not legal
otherwise we're in some sort of a weird
dictatorship you know this is not you
can't just decide it's legal but you're
the one gets to make money [ __ ] you it's
a plant that's crazy
imagine if you owned all the pine trees
in the country it's all me it's my
country my pine trees you want to buy
pond you're buying it from me I find you
with a [ __ ] Christmas tree I'll take
you out crazy
no what happened last week was calm oh I
don't know in New York he said he wants
to legalize weed oh yeah he wants to
make his recreation York stupid to shoot
down you should be making money off of
it it exists no matter what you do if
you're a capitalist if you're your
person who believes in free market you
already have whiskey you already have
pills people can get high they're not
sober just they're just not stop with
the childish arguments give the [ __ ]
people freedom and make money off it you
dummies that's what everybody should be
doing they should make it legal and
profit off it and they wouldn't stop
with that either it should go to
mushrooms should go to a lot of
different things they should set up
clinics she set up places where people
can go through mushroom therapy people
that have suffered they're coming back
from the war PTSD you
there's there's so many different
Bennett's for depression people that are
getting ready to you know to pass away
they have extreme anxiety a lot of that
is alleviated by mushrooms people that
have gone through like extensive cancer
treatment and realize their terminal one
of the best things for these people is
mushrooms it helps them eases their pain
and suffering in their last dying days
and it doesn't seem to have any negative
effects
you know other than the occasional
person losing their [ __ ] marbles
which is gonna happen no matter what you
do it's it's something that should be
studied and it's not something that
should be free and it could benefit
people so it should be [ __ ] legal I
think if everybody models what
Colorado's doing people see it you know
there's a lot of naysayers in this
business and they don't understand that
in Colorado you get tax rebates tell me
that Colorado's real estate went through
the [ __ ] roof yeah you know this is
this is something that I hope most
states go for and I know that there's a
back angle to it it's a gateway drug
it's this it's that it depends what you
do with it you know only argument is
traffic fatalities that's the only
argument I have have we had a lot of
increase in traffic fatalities but what
I've read is it depends on who it's a
problem is it's hard to find the study
that's absolutely correct some say
there's been an increase some say the
increase increase corresponds to the
population increase I've read that too
I don't know if that's true but that
kind of makes sense that if you get more
people in the city you're gonna have
more people driving you have more
traffic accidents period so if the
number just goes up but the population
is increased by 14 percent or whatever
it's done that would kind of make sense
but also let's be honest some people
don't drive very well when they're high
and if you're out there driving high and
spacing out you're a [ __ ] idiot
you might slam into a car that's
entirely possible - and to deny that
that's possible seems silly but I think
that it's like everything else there's
people that are responsible people and
there's people that aren't and there's
people that are good drivers there's
people that aren't there's people that
drive is tracted there's people that
don't pay attention to [ __ ] and then
there's people that do you know whether
they're high or sober I would rather
have you driving
then a lot of people driving sober I
know you don't [ __ ] with your phone when
you're driving I've seen you drive you
drive you take it [ __ ] seriously you
look around you know you're not
interested in getting any stupid car
accident cuz you weren't paying
attention I've seen you drive I'll
[ __ ] take you high any day of the
week I'll Drive with address it was a
cell phone addiction I Drive very
defensively i watch everything i watch
everything coming from all angles
especially today you have to
double-check everything when you drive
yeah our dear friend when we live when
they leave me got hit by a car dog yeah
heard three weeks ago
crossing the [ __ ] Street she broke
both her legs yeah I want people to
understand that you have to have your
eyes open oh I don't take nothing for
granted I don't care that guys stopping
there when I'm making that right I'm
watching that [ __ ] plus I got a
watch for pedestrians because they will
walk out anywhere next thing that you
drag on a guy three [ __ ] blocks so I
did not know the one who was hit by a
car yeah she was in a car accident no
she she was in - listen - right away the
whole thing I mean somebody was telling
me the story I mean it was just you have
to pay [ __ ] attention so I Drive
there's only a little New York in my
drive there's only a little New York in
my drive number two I Drive away from
the people I do take the two or three
car lengths I never did that to about
ten years ago my rear-ended somebody you
know you know we're driving in a place
where you have to assume unless you're
[ __ ] stupid that 30% of the people
for the last ten years have been driving
high then you gotta had another 20% for
people that are texting and driving
then you gotta add another 10% for
people who are just visiting it and I'm
looking around going oh my God look how
beautiful California is hmm it's a [ __ ]
every time you get the car you have to
drive a certain way was it how I thought
20 years ago no I want to get there why
do you think I'm against high speed cars
I wanted to ninety Joe
I'm getting the Porsche I'm doing lately
I ripped it take it up you give me a
pickle I'm ripping I knew you were gonna
get rid of those Cadillacs for a while
but you decided not to there's another I
gotta forgive you see my feet my foot is
very large they're very large and once
they rest on you it's 90 okay so that
gas pedal I made it to San Diego and
back
don't say anybody don't tell people is
secret it's not illegal okay I'm sick
and tired of people coming to me going
oh my god
to drive to San Diego was horrific what
time did you go 1:00 in the afternoon
can I smack you now or should I smack
you in the mouth later that's four hours
that's three and a half but isn't that
crazy that it takes that long but if you
get in your car at 9:00 and you do
[ __ ] 80 because all you need to do is
get out of LA once you pass the Commerce
Casino it's a river of dirty nobody
gives the Frenchman's [ __ ] you stain
that second to left lane and you're just
doing 75 baby
it's an hour an hour 45 on the way back
I made it from La Jolla an hour 30 whoa
because I that's the easy route soon as
you hit the five north you're banging
out the hole were quick all the way to
Camp Pendleton yeah Haiti you know I'm
saying you don't give a [ __ ] so you got
[ __ ] serious on it's nobody out there
it's a weird area though too when you're
coming back from San Diego says
militarize and you're hit 80 80 80 80 80
then when the road starts to thin that
means you're about to hit immigration
they're gonna ask you if you got oranges
you know you know what how they never up
there
those [ __ ] head without this is
911 all right you just once I hit that
point I kick it to a hundred till I hit
her vine once I hit a vine spectrum I
come down til about 80 80 80 80 and
that's the highway 19 miles back up to a
hundred but then you're gonna hit
traffic because you're gonna hit the ten
to five everybody's hooking up you did
good
1:01 but can I get back on that 134
please
and that 134 neat no ha the five goes
into the 134 and next thing are you home
no drama the night driving from San
Diego is the way they do it yeah you
definitely want to drive home after the
kid you don't away for the morning [ __ ]
though sometimes you're so tired you
scared no no that morning that we all
got morning it's two hours no you stop
get yourself a nice coffee hmm and you
[ __ ] Zhuang it all the way back to
Lawson no you're right that's what you
definitely should do but man with that
you know which the key for folks who you
worry about falling asleep in your car
while you driving get a rag or a t-shirt
and get some ice it's the best wet rag
with ice in it is the best just rub it
on your face real quick and you wakes
you right the [ __ ] up and it lasts for a
few minutes then just do it again a few
minutes later and you'll be fine the
whole way home if you can keep ice and a
like a washcloth or something like that
with ice in it and it gets wet just keep
rubbing your face it's better than
anything I used to smack myself in the
face
when I was getting up early in the
morning to do newspapers when I was
delivering newspapers then I would do
gigs at night I was [ __ ] tired man
and I would be coming back you know at
midnight from this gig and I knew I had
to get up at 5:00 a.m. to deliver
newspapers depending upon the day and
I'm talking smack myself in the face
because I was falling asleep at the
wheel I would just feel my eyes getting
heavy and I'm opening them up and I
couldn't keep it I just [ __ ] whack
and if you whack yourself in the face it
lasts for like a couple of minutes like
you're like Jesus oh just my whole face
would be stinging you know just like
seriously slap myself really hard in the
face whenever a [ __ ] coffee guy I
thought I was as a kid I mingled in
Cuban coffee but I just straight away
from it so when I first started Tribble
runs I would have my kid at 2:00 in the
afternoons on Sunday and I don't get off
stage and Boise Idaho
I had 11:30 at Schiphol run my car would
be filled with gas and I'd get in it
right in hell four or five rows no doves
and I would go to a gas station get the
biggest mountain to do
a little and that would thought was six
hours I would eat no dose but one of the
worst experiences I ever had was I was
falling asleep like I was done and it
was [ __ ] ten below zero you know and
I pulled over on the side of the road
I turned my lights on I put the brake
lights on and I kicked the seat back and
laid down with the heat blasting and the
car was out and at one point you're
rolling I opened up my eyes and I
thought I had lost control at all in
your mind you feel like it but I lose
them haven't be holding on to steering
wheel he says my heart almost stopped
and going thank God and get [ __ ] hit
here but I was in nodos this is way
before red blue Bull Red Bull whatever
that [ __ ] is yeah well I still remember
doing coke all night and shooting a
short film for Fox and I'll never forget
that [ __ ] they gave me two red bulls
I drank two of them and I still fell
asleep and ever since that I go Red Bull
[ __ ] the [ __ ] is a Red Bull yeah yeah
the [ __ ] Red Bull don't do dick hey
what do you think of this John John [ __ ]
what's going on do you know what's
happened the AFC's moving from Vegas I
saw this last when I got home from the
comedy store break it down for me I'm
having Jeff Novitzky come on and
breakdown scientifically on Thursday a
lot of people calling [ __ ] including
Daniel Cormier
I talked to call me on the phone he was
like he tested positive again do you
believe this [ __ ] and they get a little
fight I found out about it from Cormier
Kwami he told me they're gonna move the
fight to LA I go no yes Joe don't move
with the fight to LA I'm like no this
can't be real it didn't seem real like I
don't believe this I looked at his core
me aids Twitter and I said it's a he
tested positive again and then I looked
that one what this is like first thing
in the morning and he's like again again
but from what I understand from reading
Ariel Helwani zhh transcript of his
interview with Andy Foster and hearing
what Jeff Novitzky
has had to say about it what it is is
the num the the amount of it is so
infinitesimal and it's the exact same
metabolite that he had been screened for
that he tested positive for a year ago
and that this [ __ ] could stay in a
system in those kind of sizes of the
molecule it's like some 500 millionth of
a grain of sand or something like that
see Google with the actual number of the
how small this molecule is so Andy
foster has said again through this
transcription of this interview that he
did with Ariel Helwani that it's the
same metabolite for the same substance
they tested positive for that is the
same instance that the the number of it
and it indicates that this is something
he's already been punished for it's the
same exact he's already gone through his
you know his steps and this is just a
infinitesimally small metabolite that's
that's what I'm hearing so I would love
to hear someone who doesn't think that
that's the case that thinks there might
be some way to gain the system and the
big thought that people always bring up
when it comes to stuff as micro dosing
if someone micro dosing like you're the
one who told me about that first you
were telling me about somebody Alex
Rodriguez yeah who is taking he'll be
bad Tommy Bennett Ostrom yeah he was so
he would be up for the seventh eighth
and ninth inning but by the time the
tenth inning came if they tested him it
would be out of his system so I would
imagine the testing is better now and
it's one of the things is that Nowitzki
once get into that the testing is far
superior now so you're able to pick up
these metabolites in much much smaller
quantities okay this is so this test is
from December 9th
yes I want to see what his test was
leading up to that apparently was clean
before that he said we were notified
early this month of an issue he has had
over his most recent tests where a very
small amount of fact described how small
it is of a long-term metabolite
substance called d h CMT known as oral
turin the ball turn a ball which is the
reason
for his most recent suspension a year
and a half ago a very very small amount
but there was a number that where does
it say the number there was a knack
right
yeah something like how much smaller it
is in a grain of rice is it can't find
ya let's try finite yeah look I get how
everybody would be [ __ ] pissed I get
how everybody would think that he's a
cheater he's cheating again I get that
you would think that but I don't know if
that's true and if it's not true it
would be a shame to accuse him of it if
it is the same stuff that was in his
system that was ruled to be from a
tainted supplement here it is a picogram
is one trillionth of a gram novitskiy
said if you put one grain of salt on the
table and split it up into 50 million
pieces a picogram is one of those pieces
of that gram of salt which is insane so
that grain of salt it's some 50 million
times large or smaller than that it's
crazy so it's very very very very small
so if this is true and they believe it's
true and the guy runs California State
Athletic Commission
Andy Foster I have a great great deal
tremendous amount of respect for that
guy very proactive with weight cutting
very proactive with weight class is very
proactive with a lot of the rules he's
really good if he believes that this is
scientifically been proven to be from
the same exact thing that he already has
been punished for I agree with them I
just that that guy knows what the [ __ ]
he's talking about he's legit so is
Nowitzki so are these people that are
all saying that it's legit here's the
question though have other people been
still punished for the exact same crime
have other people tested positive again
for the exact same thing this I do not
know and I don't know if people are
looking into that if there is any
preferential treatment that would be
where the argument would be with
preferential treatment he's [ __ ]
tainted supplements are a legitimate
problem
I mean Nowitzki showed us hundreds and
hundreds of supplements you could
at any store that has you know vitamins
and muscle builders and all those kind
of things that test positive for
steroids there's a [ __ ] ton of a mouth
there man
you can get a lot of stuff in these
system but then there's also people that
are taking steroids so how do you know
who to the only way to find out who's
who is don't take [ __ ] don't take
anything unless his third-party test it
don't think anything controversial don't
take anything squirrelly and sometimes
people do and it's [ __ ] up that you
know they maybe they like a supplement
maybe they've had good results with it
and then they get one bad batch that's
possible too I just want to know that
this was from December night I want to
know what the levels of that drug they
found were before December 9 it takes a
long time I understand so but every time
you urine the level should get lower and
lower and lower I think what they're
saying is this is the lowest detectable
number so so lower than them so they
should have found this before maybe this
higher maybe not depending the did see
these numbers the way it's been
explained to me again I'm not a [ __ ]
scientist but the way it's been
explained to me this number is so small
that it could conceivably be tested in
one test and not tested another test and
then also as the testing procedures get
more and more thorough they get better
at it they're detecting things that
couldn't detect maybe even just a year
ago like it's continue the technology is
to continuing to grow and they're
getting much better at understanding how
to use it how to how to advance it so
it's not as simple as you test positive
a year ago you test negative today like
they might have better methods of
detection today than they had a year ago
you got arrested today Joe the judges on
the fake Joe Rogan I'm releasing you on
bail but the DEA wants you to take a
urine test right to the samples and if
you come back dirty the first you way is
free they know who Joe Rogan is you're
gonna go in there and you're THC levels
gonna be off the chain this is gonna be
off the chain this
the other chain when they come back they
gonna coy and they lose your Rogen this
is what it was now this is this the next
time we test it the bell not be higher
than 26% doesn't know you using this
isn't 97 yeah he told me right I'll know
if you use it on that and I stayed to
the program and I went down down down
down down and then I joined the
voluntary group and my buddy sent me an
eighth of PI weed I loved him was smokin
enjoying going back and the guys like
Dawg did you smoke a joint before you
came in for the test it was like levels
we've never seen before this is I'm
telling you about this this is a funny
joke and whatever but I want to see the
test before the 9th and I want to see
the test the most recent test those
levels haven't go down unless I
understand we're saying to us he's not
necessarily correct unless he did this
steroid during nun competition season
which they were allowed to do whatever
the [ __ ] no they're not that's not true
they never know they can never take
steroids there's a band list of things
they can never have in their system they
see if you are fighting they'll still
test you say if you don't have a camp
you're not in your on camp you don't
have about lined up they still do Joey
Diaz how are you come on in the bathroom
we're gonna get some get some fluids
from you now I don't know if they use in
just urine or Verde's if it's urine and
blood I'm not sure with the protocol but
I do know that it's very thorough and
they're catching people for things that
they would have never caught them for in
the past and this is one of the things
about this test it could possibly be as
it's been explained to me that this this
number is so [ __ ] small that they
might not even been able to detect it a
year ago but this number this insanely
small number there's new levels of
detection now whereas he would be
completely negative X amount of time in
the past now they can test it and they
could find that insanely 50 millionth of
a grain of salt
size particle it's it's so [ __ ] small
that they weren't able to catch
something like that X amount of time in
the past
whether it's a year ago or two years but
now they can and in the future it's
gonna be even better they're gonna keep
getting better at this stuff as they
advance the technology that's as it's
been explained to me what you're seeing
here what you're seeing here is not
evidence of new drug use it's evidence
that the testing is far better and that
he has the exact same metabolites and he
definitely did have it in the system
because they're finding it a year later
in this teeny tiny amount his body
hasn't completely gotten rid of it yet
still in there the question is how long
is that stuff stay in your system
they've said through normal detection I
believe Google this make sure this is
correct but through normal detection
what's not I mean from whatever the time
they they wrote this stuff out I believe
they're saying it can be detected up to
18 months but again as this technology
gets better and they can detect smaller
and smaller particles it's potentially
possible that that might extend so you
might not just be 18 months it might be
19 or 20 or who knows how long it takes
for your body to get rid of that [ __ ]
the guys like Cormier and Gustafson and
guys that you know they look at this is
where there's smoke there's fire oh yes
you know and there's they have a point
to they have a point oh so I'm not mad
at them for that I'm a big fan of John
Jones person I am too for what he does I
love them to death when I saw him in
Albuquerque came to the show we laughed
I don't think I don't know what to think
anymore you know I don't know what to
think
this one really you know and I feel bad
we you and I both know this is the car
of the year it's a phenomenal cause the
card when people fly in and it made
plans around it and they do a bunch of
stuff around it I feel bad for those
people I know what this is like for them
they just was this Saturday night
activity well in Vegas it takes a big
hit too because this was gonna be taking
place in Vegas all those people are
gonna be in town it's gonna be a
tremendous amount of money for the
casinos and you know that I'm sure it
was a lot of money for them there it was
but it's a big thing to have there and a
bigger arena so they're moving it to the
forum which is a smaller place
the forum in Inglewood is I don't know
how much smaller does the t-bone mobile
arena but he said he was Dana was saying
he could make about six million dollars
on the gate and t-mobile Arena and he's
gonna be lucky to make a million in the
forum that makes sense it's just it's
different prices too in vase and also
the fact that it's such short timing I
don't know what they do with the
original tickets I don't know how it
works this is what happened the very
first UFC I ever did the very first UFC
ever work was in Dothan Alabama UFC 12
but was supposed to be in New York State
they cancelled in New York State they
wouldn't let him do it and then they
they switched the whole thing overnight
down to Dothan Alabama I take one of
them helicopter plane and flying a
[ __ ] Dothan it was weird
it was weird back then man but that's
that's the only time I've ever heard of
something changing this close to that
was one day this is one week I've never
heard of an event changing like this
before not that I could remember I don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening
I really don't but they seemed very
confident that you're not dealing with
someone who's taking a drug again you're
dealing with the very same drug that he
took X amount of months ago still in a
system the drug he's already been
punished for I understand that people
get mad but you you don't want to accuse
someone of something that they're not
really guilty of he's definitely guilty
of taking it the first time people are
accusing them of being stupid and taking
it again
I don't think that's true I don't know
for a fact but what I'm reading from
actual experts leads me to believe that
they're making sense but I would have to
you know I'd have to talk to someone who
disagrees who knows more about it than
me to really form an opinion so my
opinion is like well if I had a bet I
would say he probably didn't do anything
but I would like to talk to someone
who's like a real [ __ ] expert who
could break down exactly what the
process is who can tell you if it is
even possible that this could be from
another ingestion somewhere along the
line and you let me tell what the sad
sad thing about this whole situation is
what they really
really from the bottom of my heart was a
great card oh it's a great car you don't
win BJ pens on the card and nobody even
talks about it yeah nobody even mention
BJ pad well you know BJ stuff fights I
was looking for Carlos and Michael J's
you know Amanda Nunez and Cyborg I
haven't slept for a week all right put
the car to figure that fight out Jon
Jones Gusterson just to look at it let's
pretend it's still in Vegas you know you
got a guy who's been active a guy who's
been fighting a guy who's angry a guy
who felt he beat Jon Jones the first
time against a very very talented
dangerous and rested Jon Jones is their
ring dust you know is their ring rust
I'm sorry ring dust what the [ __ ] am I
talking about you know look at this you
know man in a Kris cyborg has been
bitch-slap and [ __ ] since day
one a man the Nunez is something that
you taught me about that's not around
anymore and that's being slick a man the
Nunez is very slick she's taking out
some tough opponents you know she hits
very hard he hits very you know long
arms really watch those rocks and Carlos
kinda with Michael chaser this is a
great [ __ ] fight right here you know
amad Mendez Alexander Volkov ski [ __ ]
tremendous by - Chad Mendes looks
amazing in his comeback fight when you
go scroll back up to the Cris cyborg
event Chris Korey Anderson's
leather is real hard breaking his wife
seven months pregnant mmm no they gotta
get that away you know this has yeah
it's a disaster but this honestly guys
was one of those cards that I look at
and go okay what are the main two fights
I know
favorite on paper you gotta go over
cyborg and John Jones but guess what
people you never seen a bookie with a
part-time job so somebody's got to lose
one of these fights keeps groans if you
don't mind season to think about Chris
cyborg is she's not just good she's good
and ball cats and gah know Megan and
this
and aundrea Lasky's fighting on this
card she's Australian gotta say Meegan
Meegan whatever you don't think I'm no
[ __ ] English major you got BJ bad
Ryan [ __ ] Hall I think that's the
first fight of the a yes yeah yeah crazy
yeah I saw big good cars and I know on K
bump on Instagram the other day she
looks phenomenal
she looks [ __ ] phenomenal so it's a
shame that this had to be done I'm sorry
listen I'm I'm happy that the fights are
taking place I'm sorry I'm just happy
that they've taken I'm sorry that
everybody gets their life disrupted and
the families have to go from Vegas to LA
to see the fight I'm sorry about all the
hotel [ __ ] that they have to deal
with but I'm very happy that the fight
is still taking place I would love it if
Oba ran a [ __ ] special for people
just a flat yeah just run a flat for
[ __ ] people out of Vegas 300 never
gonna happen though you never know each
other and you never know you never know
people need [ __ ] action come on let's
go boys step up [ __ ] make a flat rate
for three [ __ ] people to [ __ ] forum
and 300 back people would do it it's
driving an uber some guy farting in a
car all the way from Vegas to LA why
would you do that when you take a flight
because the flights not that expensive
Uber's bro it is on a day's notice is it
how much the Southwest cost its 255
here's the van 303 is your teacher I had
a car with a guy farting for three or
four three three hundred divided by
three I save two hundred something Joe
wrong we have to look at them from their
perspective you know they've already
[ __ ] taken away and said Stan they're
losing the day of work this is a lot
well also they can't gamble like a lot
of people love the combination of
gambling gambling go to the show exacts
a lot of people stuck a lot of people
gonna [ __ ] I just take my money from the
ticket yeah and staying gamble next day
or whatever because what's it gonna cost
me to ooh but la get out party whoo look
you gonna come to a lane just get in the
car
that's you're trying to tell me now you
want to go to a party yeah Oh
what's his name John Jones might be
having a party
Carlos conduit might be having half the
party Uriah Hall I think you're right
all's on this card too busy I wasn't in
the yeah Uriah halls on this card I
think yeah yeah you have to be oh wow
yeah yeah okay we didn't see look at
this part you God knows who's having
Brian calendars on us fight and Kurtis
millander that is a [ __ ] sleeper
fight right there yeah no yeah it's a
[ __ ] Beast Kurtis millander that guy
is he's got serious potential he's got
like superstar future superstar
potential he's very good that's a that's
good fight I like that a lot
Kurtis millander is the one he fought
Thiago Alves and stopped him right click
on that make sure that's correct
does it show his record does it show his
record how good is their website now is
pretty good yeah that's it
Thiago Alves he beat Thiago Alves yeah
and then he beat max Griffin he's a
beast man he's very good
real real massive future potential and
by her design it knocks people dead he
hits hard
that's a sleeper fight that's a fight
that no one's talking about very very
good fight it's gonna be a great card
man I'm happy the cards happening I hope
everybody gets compensated I'm sorry
that the UFC loses money I'm sorry that
everybody gets dragged through I don't
understand why they couldn't just figure
out this in Nevada it's like this I
guess they're on vacation or some [ __ ]
that's so crazy like figure it out
everybody let's make a phone call like
isn't there one person who could like
some person should say okay is it to the
best of your knowledge absolutely from
the original test yes sir by all the
science we're gonna submit the science
and we show you the science when tell
you the number okay let him fight the
[ __ ] you let them fight you gotta let
them fight California let him [ __ ]
fight Nevada stupid how [ __ ]
stupidity raka see it's just dumb stupid
that in this case it's due this case
it's a [ __ ] they're on vacation yes
well let's have a [ __ ] emergency
meeting yeah let's save big
the tourism board in Vegas must be
steaming hey ask this ask this Google
this find out who's disputing if anybody
dispute if anybody like makes any sense
if there's a scientist or someone like
that who says that it could be micro
dosing or that it did that what the
California State athletic commissions
understanding of it is not correct let's
find out there's anybody that has
written anything about that I'm upset I
just wanted this fight to take place
without any [ __ ] behind it I just
want it to be a great fight it's a it's
an amazing match out I think Gustafson
especially against Glover Teixeira has
never looked better he's he's long as
John he's got crazy footwork he's the
older first guy to ever take John down
it was a [ __ ] tough fight regardless
of whether or not John prepared much for
it I don't think he did prepare as good
as you could have Gustafson's better I
think than he was when that fight took
place I really do think he's better it's
uh it's [ __ ] phenomenal it's an
amazing fight and John's gonna be so
motivated to try to get stripped the way
he got stripped all the different things
that he's [ __ ] up to have a chance at
redemption it's gonna be so emotive in
but you also have to consider the
incredible amount of pressure he's going
to be under - historically though he's a
guy who shines under pressure I mean
stop shogun and his first title fight
when he was what was he 22 or something
like that he's a monster
john has always been good at fighting
top-level competition good at handling
the stress this is you know it's a
different kind of stress this is I
[ __ ] up stress it's not this is a big
fight this is a big fight plus I [ __ ]
up and everybody knows I [ __ ] up and
this is not even the current [ __ ] it's
reminding him of the past [ __ ] up and
then there's the other stuff the car
accident and all the other crazy [ __ ]
all of it's bad but he has an
opportunity at redemption it's just when
you know how much is on the line because
he's undefeated right except for the
Matt Hamill fight which we know he was
destroying Hamill and he was
disqualified it wasn't a real loss like
somebody beat him he's beaten everybody
that's unprecedented
outside of khabib nurmagomedov nobody
beats everybody Jon's beaten everybody
so there's going to be a certain amount
of people that
looking forward for him to fail and he
feels that too
so a lot going on man it's a lot going
on in this fight and Gustafson is
[ __ ] good you see the combination he
knocked out clover Teixeira with whoa
that's like some videogame [ __ ] man it
was like he was in mortal combat it was
tremendous his footwork everything I was
really who I got a work Saturday night
I'm working I'm relaxed not all week
are you really yeah I forgot I thought
it was this last week up so I thought it
was this last weekend so I called the
store I call then and then I go [ __ ] no
I'm not missing and I called back and
cancelled and then like Wednesday I go
what the [ __ ] am I thinking so I ended
up back at the store Saturday night I
squeezed onto Brian's shelf I got to see
Tiffany Haddish I hadn't seen her since
she busted out became a star it was
great just to see her [ __ ] with her
and then last night I went down then
there was two shows there was I'm
leaving they're like hey you won't open
up for sure pal I know sure pal where
they know if he's doing his show in the
belly room there was a [ __ ] line
around the corner unless something that
I pulled out I was like this is crazy
this is getting so [ __ ] insane I took
two weeks off from gettin on stage after
la hoy I did too late some lawyer and
that was tremendous to each other on the
high is amazing you know law is the room
you go to when you want to put you want
to thread that hour together they take
the right with you that's one of the few
rooms this takes the right we do two
shows a night down there yeah yeah yeah
that place is amazing it's like a comedy
store south yeah really is a little bit
more loose yeah even though it's Friday
the sound it will let you try some new
[ __ ] they're fun people down there man
very fun that's a nice area like
dobutamine Diego has a lot of the same
qualities that LA has but it's more like
a little bit more the rest of the
country boy is beautiful boy it was went
to Ron on jujitsu I trained when they
the place is right next to the [ __ ]
candy store
really yeah I just looked it up called
the guy was awesome Levin you know La
Hoya is that's why you moved to when you
got a lottery this that's a lot of down
there
he lives on that Coronado Island doesn't
he where Donald Rumsfeld I don't know
who [ __ ] was gotta rich dudes but it
is just gorgeous you can't see at night
there's no lights on the streets there's
nothing they encourage that listen 9:30
go to bed go to [ __ ] bed go to bed
all right we don't want you wanna mingle
they'll [ __ ] down this hour whatever
Street Scotty Shore lives down there he
showed up did he he showed up on
Saturday okay yeah hug it was great to
see him he has a little dog with him he
had the little dog cuz I do it joking
but I gotta get his dick sucked with a
dog so at the end he goes the night
inspires Ebola no no I did see the dog
he came down to see loose don't playing
the piano I mean the county store down
there did not lose anything except Mitzi
sure
plus it's got more [ __ ] on the walls
that you look at him really makes you
think
mmm there's pictures of green room for
Jim Carrey and Paul Rodriguez and Dice
Clay and Louie Anderson at the time that
they didn't even know that we're gonna
be stars yes we done down there yeah we
said a lot of shows when did we first
started working together down there I
think the first nineties oh yeah it was
late night the first time I went down at
one time there was a girl comic who was
it I don't remember what her name was it
was a very uncomfortable weekend she was
clean
oh you had to stay in the condo with her
yeah oh that's crazy I read there
imagine a girl being forced to stay in a
condo with a guy that you don't even
know she stayed in the headline
I stayed in the feature room at that
time still it's weird then I went down
there she wouldn't book me down there
but once she started booking me she
booked me a lot Mitsy yeah I remember
one going down there one time and I went
down there with Marilyn Martinez and her
husband and we weren't there in the hour
and Marilyn Martinez husband comes out
with a [ __ ] rat well with a rat in a
trap the trap that he set he does we
won't hear [ __ ] like as the
rumor was there were rats down there be
careful
Oh so he went down and said traps up
within the power you did bah oh my god
the [ __ ] thing had to be 9 inches
long the tail and I'll never forget
going on the balcony and hearing them in
the weeds I packed up my little sleep
apnea machine and I [ __ ] drove back
home
I [ __ ] hate rats well this door has
so many rats that back area oh my oh my
god they're [ __ ] popping out every
time you're sitting back there there's a
little for folks that are listening to
us there's a little back bar area where
only comics and their friends can go and
behind the back bar is a smoking area
and that smoking area has these railroad
ties these railroad ties these rats will
run in and out of these ties and over
the Jew feel like all the time all the
time if I'm back there for more than 15
minutes I've seen a rat and if you go
near the hedges by the dumpster that's
where they really are where where the
back area is not that big it's the hills
the hills are filled with rats the
Hollywood Hills are filled with rats
occasionally we have cats that hang
around the park amount economy store
like local feral cats but they don't get
the rats because the rats go in the
[ __ ] the vines those vines that cover
the side of the comedy store ramp the
ramp that leads up to the Andaz hotel
those vines are all rats
that's a rat village it's crazy how much
sound they make when you're parking a
car you hear i'm scurrying there's like
probably hundreds of rats there dude
I know whenever I parked my car my dump
site close the windows
Oh because I know I don't want to jump
into a car with a [ __ ] listen to me I
just leave [ __ ] and leave Aspen
I don't like $80,000 I got any people
looking for me the cops are looking for
me
I go from Aspen to Boulder and I need a
job so I take a job making Jo I'm not
kidding 160 a week 60 hours Wow as a
[ __ ] shag which I'm the guy that
takes a car from me in the body shop
when you pull up on me and it takes it
and I wash it and they start the
bodywork and then after they've done the
bodywork I'm the guy that washes and if
he do that for three or four months then
they turn you into a detailer and I
passed the test memory game indeed they
hit 160 dollars a week all it was
[ __ ] garbage I was starving starving
but I was good and I became a detail but
the detailing was commissioned and you
made a hundred to a buck fifty a day and
you know I was enjoying it but the guy I
had as a boss was a dish his name was
dirt Jordan he was just a dick so he was
one of those guys that was one of us but
when they get to manage his job I'm one
then I'm back there washing the [ __ ]
car and I see a dead rat and I picked
the [ __ ] rat up and he had his jacket
hanging by the door
I put the dead rat in his pocket that
was jagged right you know me thought I
go home I get stoned I don't know
nothing the next morning he comes in bro
and his cat cause [ __ ] up like he hit
like a pole he went in his pocket to get
a cigarette ah
and he pulled the [ __ ] rat out and he
[ __ ] just went crazy and hit like a
pole he came in running I know who did
this I'm gonna get for the bottom of
this that he can't blame it some other
guy
Oh bosses
[ __ ] man that's one of the worst
relationships ever a boss an employee
one of the worst relationships some guy
gets to tell you what to do
he's the [ __ ] he's the head guy at
the office you gotta listen to this
[ __ ] that is one of the worst
positions to be in working for a guy
who's a dick and that power that someone
would have you know if you were you
moved on up
he became the office manager you can
control people's future control where
they get a raise how much time they get
off you can make the decisions well then
I allowed him to do certain things what
was [ __ ] terrible was the wars boss
you bad let's come on and be clean
was the first caption what was the first
guy you looked at and said you know what
if I have a see outside am I'm a [ __ ]
yeah I never said that but uh guys in
construction they would get real Dicky I
did one time there was a guy when I was
a teenager that was talking about the
shed he would hit me with a hammer yeah
there was a because he got he got
aggressive with me and it was and it
wasn't in a way where I deserved it he
was just bullying me and I was like 16
17 but I had already had a [ __ ] load of
fights by then like you know talk about
no fights I was like dude I'll kick you
in your [ __ ] head like you talk much
crazy [ __ ] to me like this like he was
talking to me in not just a way like a
boss employee he was talking to me in a
way where I was gonna have to quit but I
never never never said I was gonna do
anything to him I didn't like threat and
I would say I'll see you after this and
I'll [ __ ] you up I said don't talk to me
like that cuz I could [ __ ] you up
that's basically what I said but it was
that's the thing about constructions
like there was a lot of like man-to-man
type conflict like it wasn't unheard of
to hear about street fights between guys
who are working together they got pissed
and pushed each other and punched each
other in the [ __ ] snow you know dudes
carrying roofing tiles one guy knocks
another guy over or something they start
fighting that she had happened all the
time there's a lot of the people that
were doing labor - were like real
dirtbag
like there was this one guy that I did
labor with um I worked my friend Leroy
Rodriguez and his buddy they had some
business partner that would take apart
old houses and redo them and Leroy was
one of the black belts at the the
Taekwondo Institute he was a bad
[ __ ] and Leroy got me this gig
and I worked with these guys labor and
one of the guys we work with lived in
this [ __ ] up abandoned building what
not abandoned but stripped out building
I mean there was parts of the building
where there's no floor was all [ __ ] up
half the walls were missing they were
redoing the whole building and taking
things out and fixing things this guy
lived there and he had a mountain Dew
jug filled with malt liquor and he would
drink it warm all day and he'd had the
shakes everything he did the dude had
the shakes he was just drunk all day on
a crazy job site where like you know
there's no floors sometimes sleep
everything it's all [ __ ] up you have
to balance when you're going from one
room to the other because they're
tearing down parts the wall and this guy
somehow another [ __ ] slid on through
drinking the entire time and I remember
thinking like these are people that have
made questionable decisions it makes you
want to go back to college makes you
want to get a degree when you're around
a lot of these guys like laborers and
stuff like you know some of them were
just like me they're just young guys who
need a gig and they need money and some
of them are dudes have been doing it
their whole life and they're 50 and
they're drunk yeah terrible bye yeah I
definitely knew I didn't want to do it I
definitely knew I didn't want to do it
well you know be a carpenter as a
different gig you know like a real good
carpenter that's a skilled craftsman and
an artist you know you're putting
together things that's different but the
laborer gig was not like you didn't
really have to know anything he just had
to be big enough to listen to them you
know picking up so he could pick things
up can you go get that go get me that
bag of cement go dude all right you guys
gonna take nails out of these boards now
and there was like that kind of [ __ ] you
just hung out with the weirdest people
Matt the worst guy I remember Joe Rogan
I was clean from coke I was clean about
90 days I was really trying to turn my
life around and I answered an ad for
construction carpenters help and he
hired me I went
the first day you had to work for free
play for free yeah he absolutely seen
yeah
so I said okay I agreed to it Wow first
they work for free
I cut the stuff and you have to go get
lunch and the whole thing yeah okay I
did it
I passed and then the guy would say okay
meet me at a diner at 8:00 and when I go
get paid he'd say what's those hours and
I go you told me to meet you at 8:00 he
goes uh no it should be a windshield
time so I say the job we didn't get to
the job by 10:00 that's when you start
getting paid that I started getting paid
and I was you know I was that I was
really trying and I lived with a friend
I want to give them rent money I was
trying to put away some money I forget
what he paid me didn't but he made me
pay for my own lunch then one day he
said uh where's your weight belt you
know you don't work belt I don't have
money no it's okay I'll pay and you have
to pay me for the materials plus thirty
percent that was a thirty percent yeah
you're a [ __ ] scumbag just to have
like a claw a [ __ ] hammer and
something else I forget what you do work
for him so would have your own tool
other sword stuff like that yeah that
was always a thing whether it's a union
or non-union you know there was a lot of
the work that I did when I was a kid was
non-union and a lot of the people didn't
want a union they felt the Union guys
they had it easier but it was it was too
expensive and people didn't want to you
know use certain people so it was it was
like a real debate like what's better
probably about a union people you have
to have a certain amount on you cuz how
it works to balance it out right so
everybody makes money but it seems like
in some things like Auto Workers they
don't [ __ ] around brakes glory time yeah
you know this lists if a job opens up
how do we get it you gotta go on a list
Brogan has more minority than D as he
started nine months before D as he gets
the job yeah you know it's not about
knowing all that [ __ ] with that dude
I'll never forget that news
name one he didn't the scumbag he was to
me but on Fridays he would make me feel
bad like he goes so how many hours did
you work and I go 38 no I'm paying you
for 30 and he'd bully me this guy but
every Friday he go this Friday I'm going
away I'm going here to [ __ ] my wife in
the ass and he was always an [ __ ]
they'll also think I'm like this from my
check I got this check I was waiting for
and once a day I'm sitting I'm like I'm
sick of this [ __ ] I'm gonna rob
his house and I jumped the fence and I
kick the back door on and he was a guy
that bought hot [ __ ] on the side snowing
showers just a bus a sack of [ __ ] and he
must have had I don't know how many
[ __ ] him bottles and cases of Dom
Perignon
so I [ __ ] ran up to the corner call
my buddy don't meet me at this address
and I took every bottle of Dom Perignon
and he had I sold him in liquor stores
I took his checkbook I mean I buried
this [ __ ] guy just for how bad he
treated me with such a [ __ ] scumbag
oh never bought lunch he was always
making crazy oh he's always making
little [ __ ] remarks well that's what
we're talking about earlier when he
offends when a guy gets into power
that's piece of [ __ ] oh my god so war is
such a [ __ ] to him yeah but I had his
t-shirt for a long time I used the word
and smile every time mm-hmm
JHS is some [ __ ] like that function
that's half with his Harvey Weinstein
things about right it's about the boss
yeah that's what it's about - what the
boss abusing his power the boss [ __ ]
the girls so they can get the job and
that's that's the offer which is
probably been going on forever man it's
like I said especially here listen they
destroyed Marilyn Monroe and that's the
ones we know millions of women that
come on here I have been put through a
[ __ ] process it was always what how
these guys got power I mean if you look
at a guy like Harvey how else is he
gonna get laid
let's be honest I mean is he gonna get
laid because he's a good-looking guy or
is he gonna get laid because he's
ruthless and very successful it would
have to be ruthless and very successful
oh it was that handsome I don't know was
it slept with him did whether not a lot
well I don't know that didn't win but I
mean there's a lot that did the story is
that there was a lot that that did it I
mean he couldn't have made these offers
all these women that said no and not
have some of them say yes it doesn't
make it any less horrible for the women
who said no and were hounded by them and
whatever went down and he ruined some
careers and but some of them had to say
yes it's just some would make that deal
with the devil that happens with a lot
of different things people make that
deal they make that deal it's worth it
you know I mean I joked around about it
in my act about Harvey know Weinstein
but that's that's what a lot of guys
would do a lot has a bang some check if
that's all it took and you can you can
get ahead you know you don't have to
marry you just have a [ __ ] how many
guys would do that a lot of guys would
do that would girls do that to some of
them yeah
most would not want that to be stuck in
front of their face most would rather
make their way through the most the vast
majority would rather get by on their
merits but there's always throughout
time there's been people that [ __ ] their
way to the top that's not a myth that's
not like angels so it's not like Pixies
and wood elves people have done it
people have done everything that you can
imagine people have married people for
money people have killed people for
their insurance premiums are their
insurance policies rather that's that
happens when people die they check the
spouse to see if the spouse how to [ __ ]
an insurance policy if they find out
they've recently put out a big fat
insurance policy then they go sideways
you all did yeah and just vanished in
the woods huh that's weird Mike Mike
have a seat we're gonna talk what
happened again Mike let's just take me
through the top tell me what happened
you guys know Mike English live in
Colorado I was another one that was
another one that just happened in Cabo
phone ended up in Idaho yeah miles away
they saw her leave the supermarket with
the child he supposedly picked her up I
want to know how you got the phone up
there member every cars GPS now yeah no
the car unless it's a little drug or you
know this there's cars they still have
the dawn of GPS this cars you get him
stripped they don't have [ __ ] in them
but it get a really cheap car a truck
pickup truck no radio that's of that
stolen that baffles me how the [ __ ] did
he get to Idaho how about the [ __ ]
guy who killed his whole family how
about that guy guy killed his wife
killed his kids yeah but that guy
[ __ ] in this price and he looked so
normal you see a picture of him as one
of the mistress camera yeah the missus
gamer but you look at him to picture him
with his family go that guy looks so
[ __ ] his own kid how is he capable of
killing his wife peep there's there's
certain people out there that just
they're [ __ ] broken they're broken
and you and if you're a woman you have
to think about that that's the
difference between women and men that's
the biggest difference the biggest
difference is women have to constantly
be in fear of a violent man whereas men
rarely are in fear of a violent woman
doesn't mean it doesn't happen it happen
to my friend Phil Hartman his wife shot
him I was asleep that did happen but the
vast majority if you're looking at like
the numbers of people that are afraid of
the opposite sex it's women that are
afraid of men it's a different
environment so different it's a
different dynamic it's not like anything
that we could ever really truly
appreciate if you know how to handle
yourself in that case that happened in
Colorado where he killed is there any
past the rest of violence I don't think
so nothing you just snapped one day bro
it doesn't make any same just left and
this guy here like I said the only thing
that blows you off is her car phone and
I know which meant he had to take her
right there drive to hi-de-ho which has
to be 11 12 hours and drive back 770
miles or what and drive back without
nobody noticing it's only pot no gas
station attendant
recognizing a truck with a child in the
back you know they have to do a search
of every gas station camera to see if he
pulled up and they didn't find him I
don't I don't think they've even gone
that deep so far hmm but they gotta
figure out how her cell phone and the
level of [ __ ] mailbox I just don't
understand where people get the [ __ ]
it is so tough to ice somebody now and
think you're gonna get away with it
between cellphones drones cameras
pictures think about it you think about
it how they find everything there it's
way more difficult that's [ __ ] rural
area rural areas you could still get
away with the law no no nothing so look
at that chick that was jogging from the
university or whatever oh that's right
and they for right a ho Iowa they caught
it with something they call a little
drunk I don't know exact number it's
very tough sorry I got a piece so bad
well then go ahead do your thing
whatever I'm gonna have pissed talked to
Jamie and I'll come back I'm not done
yet
take your time bye hurry up and [ __ ]
like that it's the holiday season you're
sitting around right now thinking you
see what's going on with Joe Rogan
that's what happens when you turn 50
[ __ ] so prepared
you drink your water you try to be
healthy but you gotta pee all [ __ ]
day this is what I live with every
[ __ ] night I go to bed I'm nice and
sleepy and at one point I got a [ __ ]
you get up and pee and it comes out nice
and slow to really torture you to really
make you think about that ham and cheese
sandwich in the [ __ ] refrigerator
should you stay up and eat that [ __ ]
think thank God it's Merry Christmas
time this is the best [ __ ] time
because listen I ain't doing dick till
Thursday you understand me how about you
Jimmy
nothing not that I ain't doing dick till
Thursday - then I'm one of the crisis
with my wife and kid we're gonna sing
minger jingle bells and all that [ __ ]
all the kids get together I'll probably
be home by 9:00 tomorrow ain't doing
dick thing about doing open mics
at the gym tomorrow for jiu-jitsu I
might have to go down there 12 just to
get some exercise again using excuse to
heat I'm thinking about dropping into
the combi store on Christmas night it
might be boring but it might be an
adventure then Wednesday I got [ __ ]
and for a Thursday Friday Saturday I'm
up there in Oxnard at 11:00 he lives
that'll be fun listen Assent it's the
weekend before New Year's who the [ __ ]
gonna show up people gonna be waiting
for New Year's cuz that's what people do
they do you know what I'm just in the
way for New Year's Eve and jump up and
down I [ __ ] hate New Year's Eve you
in the stem have always hated New Year's
Eve since I was 18 a New Year's Eve you
asking me why do you ain't [ __ ] New
Year's Eve does weird things happen when
I was 18 or 17 I saw an rx-7 hit a
[ __ ] tree on New Year's Eve when the
car got split in half and then the kid
was dead the girl got taken out by the
jaws of death then the following year I
went to a party and I saw my buddy Danny
be bite off Rogers ear and we had to
drive me to the [ __ ] hospital with a
piece of here and the [ __ ] baggy with
ice cubes so that's why you never saw me
drink on New Year's Eve
any other time when I threw you had 364
days a year
for me to snort coke and heat pills and
drink when it came to New Year's Eve I
minded my [ __ ] business why because
it's just a creepy night in fact I'm
excited that Joe Rogan's not doing New
Year's yet relax I saw that is that what
happened the guy fell asleep
yeah yeah I saw that walked away I heard
probably cuz he was asleep prayer
thought it was in a dream didn't stiffen
up that was in another country right
yeah dude I peed more than I've ever
peed in my life right now I got my blood
done recently got everything checked up
everything's groovy but I was dehydrated
so I've been making a point to drink
more water what if I keep myself D hard
but that doesn't make any sense good
drink during the show but if I do that
subconsciously to limit my needing to
pee during 3 our conversations no I
don't think so you know what man I drink
water off
from day every time I walk out of the
dentist doctors well for CEO for a
physical he always says drink more water
yeah well he still weighs just drink
more water it doesn't hurt and you know
what I would water next to me which is
Big D get up and have a sip of water
yeah I'll get up Pete and drink a
[ __ ] gallon of water and then because
of the sleep have any machines gonna put
my fluid in the well right I just bring
a bottle of water with me next door all
right to the bed was they at night and
it's really important if you read up
there's a reason there's a reason why
you know because when you're over 50 you
pee more mm-hmm but there's a read you
have to look it up when you're by
yourself next time in a hotel room
there's a reason why you should sleep
tight hydrated hmm when you're over 50
big reasons why well whenever I get
whenever I go to yoga class I always
feel like I have to make a conscious
effort to take that fluid back in cuz
you sweat so much one of those hot yoga
classes like if you don't make a real
like conscious drink of you're thirsty
you got to make kind of a conscious
effort to get those fluids back in your
body and you probably should take some
electrolytes too I'm some sort of
electrolytes up I just blast the [ __ ]
banana man that's good too I blast 2
bananas you say full yep for an hour
till 2:00 after you eat mmm I drink
water and I also drink a [ __ ] do you
have to work out drink sometimes but hat
is a good right before you work no pump
no calories no sugar no Gatorade no
[ __ ] that monster how did you drink I
don't touch nothing that ain't all that
[ __ ] dear all that's just gonna kill
[ __ ] people 20 years from now monster
energy and all those energy drinks and
[ __ ] like that they don't kill people
dawn my favorite thing is just coffee
before any kind of workout
just coffee myself do you know that
before I go to this store do you know
that before I knock on this door I drink
a four shot express four shots
you know I usually drink one of these
even shameless plug for caveman nitros
even my wife ago how big is that day and
I put that cancer sugar in there and I
[ __ ] get sugar free sugar yeah that's
a current I get in that [ __ ] car I
don't know music just to show it's just
me and 4 cups of expresso do you know
what's going through my mind if I have
the ball sometimes I take a toke off the
pipe just to cook the expresso up a
level and I pop a nicotine gum oh my god
you know why I'm juiced up by the time I
get to the Comedy Store because that's
what I put myself through the nicotine
nicotine gum is supposed to be legit
like from what I understand nicotine
itself is a really good nootropic
they've they've analyzed the cognitive
benefits of nicotine on its own but it's
addictive so it's it's I don't think
this nicotine gum is very healthy for
you but if there was a way juice right
if there was a way to blast nicotine
like maybe chew it like at the back oh
like a clean tobacco just to give you a
little hmm
push off the cliff yeah I think it's not
bad for you I never won one of the
things that it really shocked me the
cops are looking for me so I jumped on a
bus in San Francisco in 1985 it I didn't
know the bus was going was going to a
place called Reno I had never heard of
the marina and with those days you could
smoke on a bus I met the kids from
whatever Egypt and he smoked with me at
that time I was never touched a tobacco
product never even consider it I thought
I'm CUBAN like what cigars are the worst
thing in the world for you
and I'm a movie smoked a joint with hash
weed and tobacco in it huh what year was
this 1985 yeah we smoked a joint on a
bus I thought my lungs were gonna
[ __ ] cave in I wonder tobacco in the
hashish cos hash the prom in hashes no
matter what you smoked a hash
it doubles in your lungs what do you
mean it the smoke doubles in your lungs
how does it do that do I look like
Johnny [ __ ] scientist to you I don't
know next time well these smart guys
comes on the show that's why I usually
smoke ash I take a pen
you know of pens that people put job
yeah your life fire put on their glass
put under glass and you smoke it clean
because the double that wheat that
strain the hash there was something else
would double up in your [ __ ] lungs
that's why you call so hard
I remember when expands expands expands
I remember when I was a super square I
never did any drugs never smoked pot
never did anything and I went to an
agent's room I think we were in Montreal
was me and my manager in this agent who
was a friend of ours and he had a piece
of hash that he lit unlike a thumbtack
under glass he blows on it blows on it
and he puts the lid on I'm watching him
and then he smokes the hash out of it I
was like I can't believe I'm seeing this
guy do drugs like this is like a scene
in Hollywood he's here he's doing drugs
he's smoking drugs
he says hash you know I thought of hash
that [ __ ] movie Midnight Express
that's what I thought oh my god you got
to go to jail for life
you're gonna jerk off my glass like
you're gonna have to fight someone and
kill him
Midnight Express is about smuggling hash
from Turkey that's it in my mind hash
was a serious [ __ ] drug like this guy
was doing heroin are you doing hash you
might as well be doing heroin I'm sorry
kid he's just doing this in front of me
smoking hash in front of people with a
glass scares the [ __ ] out it's uh for
someone who doesn't do anything like
that's a big it's not like hitting a hit
of a joint you take a hit of a joint ago
okay guy likes to smoke pot I've seen
that before you you light a piece of
hash and put it on a thumbtack and put
it under that glass and you get down
there and suck it out of the glass you
create drug addict just sniffing exhaust
fuel the [ __ ] are you doing man if you
know anything about me you know I've
seen some weird people do some drugs
[ __ ]
when I was in New York and when I got up
early and there's a movie called sugar
hell you
I shouldn't help sugarhill I remember
the Sugar Hill Gang sugar-laden Sugar
Hill is a movie that is possibly wesley
snipes best movie sure that was when
they were the drug dealers drug be yes I
remember the Alexander opens up the
movie because she plays the mother and
she makes them hold the belt and he goes
why you gotta make me all the belt mama
because you're the oldest hold the belt
so I can shoot this goddamn hair or mom
is sick that's right this is his best
movie by [ __ ] far that was a good
movie
so I gotta wrap this up let's talk but
what are we gonna do that's it how we
can open a new year within laying bets
nothing nothing about [ __ ] Jon Jones
Gusterson if he had a Bennett you didn't
give me a breakdown here bet John Jones
vs Gustafson yeah I'm stuck on both
fights that's all I want to tell people
it's that I wouldn't bet me I can't bet
either either they're both very good
matchups very first cyborg you have to
give her an advantage because she's so
much bigger and because she just doesn't
seem to lose
she's just smashing people she's got
really really good technique and she's
super powerful and she's really big and
she's got a lot of success and then
Amanda Deena is is without a doubt the
hardest hit in bantamweight she's a
[ __ ] cool Smasher man she's a gate
great camp she's maintained long
shoulders long she keeps keep on the end
of punches she'll she's gonna test
cyborg you know we're gonna find out
whether or not she could hurt her and we
find out if she can hurt her this could
get crazy who the [ __ ] knows because
Amanda Nunez can crack if she hurts
cyborg it could get crazy but if she
can't she hits harder than Holly I think
my humble opinion I think Holly is a
great kicker and Holly is you know she's
really good at movement and she's very
durable and Holly managed to go the full
distance with cyborg you know there's a
hard fight it was a hard fight and she
lost that fight
the difference between Holly and Amanda
noonas I think is like one shot power is
better for núñez but you know Holly when
you she fought Germaine Gironda me she
when she fought Germaine
she knocked her down she knocked you
down with straight left
she hurt her she heard her a couple
times she had kicked her she hit her
with a questionmark kick and had kicked
her and Germaine de random a is really
good
heavy heavy duty Muay Thai fighter but
she didn't want to fight cyborg Holly
did how about just the biggest and the
best in terms of like her you look at
her success ratio you look at with the
way she beats girls down she's so
powerful man but Amanda is the toughest
fighter this is yeah this is this is a
fight if you go back to cyborgs fight
with gina carano gina carano one point I
was on top of her on the ground
she didn't sustain it and she lost the
fight and cyborg eventually smashed her
but there were Gina had her moments in
that fight you know and I don't think
Gina was ever the one shot cracker that
Amanda is however cyborg is way better
than she was back then but you know so
is Amanda Amanda you know coming off
with Raquel Pennington fight you watched
that fight she dominated Raquel
Pennington and I think Raquel is one of
the toughest girls in the division she's
a hard woman and she she beats a lot of
really good fighters and she she gave
Holly Holm all she could handle and got
a split decision lost Holly Holm in
Holly's debut in the UFC
I mean she's [ __ ] good and Amanda
Nunez handled her it was very very
impressive who's scary like dismantling
she's beating her up I was like wow like
she's on another level now as a champion
she's gotten even better she was always
really good she was always really
dangerous but as a champion she got even
better when she beat Ronda Rousey in 48
seconds that was the big coming-out
party like here we are baby she's she's
the best bantamweight ever you know in
terms of like her or her ability to
knock girls out like she's the scariest
of all time she's the only one I mean
cyborg can't make 135 Amanda Nunez can
she's a legit 135 champion you know and
she's got it down now - she can go five
rounds she can she can beat the [ __ ] out
of you for five rounds now it's
different I mean interesting fight but
listen Merry Christmas Merry Christmas -
the JRE family you know I love you
[ __ ] Christmas to you my friend
for Christmas - my brother was right
this week at home I don't think so
not this week but we'll see each other
soon for sure and uh after New Year all
right take everybody much
by Merry Christmas my Christmas Happy
New Year Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa
and Merry everybody
[Music]